Untertitelung des ZDF, 2020
muka w
Oh, die Soundsettings sind noch da.
Wait a minute, Windows, was ist da los?
Moment, warum kann man da jetzt nicht die Lautstärke vom Mikrofon einstellen?
Wo ist das jetzt nochmal?
Sound Settings muss man hin.
Volume, ja.
Mikrofon, nee, das ist richtig.
Okay, keine Ahnung.
Da habe ich es einfach nicht richtig auf oder so.
Ja, nee, nee, geht schon.
Excellent.
ich weiß nicht wie lange ich heute streamen soll ich bin übelst kaputt noch gestern bin ich seit
langer zeit fast mal wieder fast 15 kilometer gerannt am stück morgens zehn kilometer gelaufen
also so spazieren gegangen ein bisschen schneller nichts nix großer denn dann 15 kilometer gerannt
knapp 15 kilometer 14,88 kilometer und
ich habe es voll in den beinen gemerkt er immer noch ziemlich kaputt das war
ich nicht bin ich nicht mehr gewöhnt habe letzten monat nicht mehr so viel
gemacht und jetzt wieder seit seit so drei vier wochen oder so wieder voll
dabei und gestern war die erste richtig lange runde knapp 15 kilometer also das
letzte drittel habe ich echt gemerkt richtig also mit laufen meine
spazierengehen ja zehn kilometer halbwegs zügig spazieren gegangen da
noch 15 kilometer gejoggt vielleicht ist das verständlicher aber ja also 25
Kilometer zu Fuß,
im Endeffekt kann man sagen.
Ja.
Ja, und
also, wo ich es richtig
übertrieben habe, war, glaube
ich, letzten
Sonntag oder so.
Da bin ich irgendwie acht Kilometer
gerannt,
irgendwie dann nochmal spazieren gegangen und dann war ich
noch 52, glaube ich,
52 Kilometer Fahrrad fahren.
Aber vielleicht gehe ich
heute Fahrrad fahren, ich glaube, das Wetter ist heute ganz
gut. Weil Rennen
kann ich heute... Ich muss mal
kurz gucken, wie das Wetter heute wird.
Weil Rennen kann ich
heute... Oh ne, wird doch nicht so gut.
Kann ich heute definitiv nicht.
Nach den
15 Kilometern gestern.
Das reicht mir.
Mein Ziel ist ja immer noch
mal
Halbmarathon-Distanz demnächst.
Und man denkt sich
so, ey, wenn man 15 Kilometer
rennen kann, ohne umzukippen,
dann kann man doch auch 21 Kilometer
rennen. Oder wie lang ist
das?
Wie lang ist das? 21, oder?
Ja, 21 Kilometer.
Kann man auch
einfach 21 Kilometer rennen, also sind es
quasi 7 Kilometer mehr. Aber
darf ich vergessen,
das sieht erstmal nicht so
viel aus, aber
das ist ein Drittel länger. Und das letzte
Drittel ist eh immer das anstrengendste.
genau das das täuscht ja das ist dann doch anstrengender als man denkt ja regelmäßig
weiß nicht ob man einmal der doch regelmäßig heißt ja nur wiederkehren so sowie den gron job
im Endeffekt.
Ah, es läuft. Was ist da los?
Anzeige ist raus.
Jetzt irgendwie. Was lustig ist,
man schwitzt gar nicht so sehr.
Also wenn man eine
gewisse Geschwindigkeit Fahrrad fährt
oder auch rennt. Beim Fahrradfahren schwitzt man
beim Fahren kaum.
Also bei normalen Geschwindigkeiten.
Berghoch ist krass, dann läuft
immer wie sau aber bei normalen geschwindigkeiten schützt man kaum weil man so viel fahrtwind hat
und wenn man rennt hält sich das in grenzen hält sich zumindest auch in grenzen wenn man schwitzt
aber sobald man stehen bleibt ist halt dann läuft was rennt zu pace auf kilometer ich kann dir sagen
was gestern gerannt bin gestern war so dass ich also ich bin gestern so schnell gerannt dass ich
gedacht habe es halte ich sie durchaus trotzdem anstrengend weil einfach 15
kilometer belastung ich kann es dir sagen gestern bin ich gerannt
gestern bin ich gewusst dass den kalender manches die garmin anzeige
wirklich pp gehalter hier also gestern 14,88 kilometer
durchschnitts puls 159 durchschnittlicher pace pro kilometer 622 total time eine
stunde 34 44 und jetzt haltet euch fest kalorien verbraucht 1198 wobei ich da
immer ein bisschen weiß nicht also ich glaube dass sie diese kalorien anzeige
in den Tracking-Apps sind
sehr
optimistisch.
Aber selbst wenn es nur 800 waren, ist es immer noch ordentlich.
Danach
habe ich erstmal gefressen. Ja, klar.
Aber es ist logisch. Also, ich muss sagen,
es gibt ja mittlerweile
schon ein paar Untersuchungen zu,
dass es gar nicht so sehr das
Sportmachen ist, wovon man
abnimmt.
Sondern eher durch den erhöhten Verbrauch, den man
dann so den restlichen Tag über hat. Aber
Aber Sport machen führt nicht zwangsläufig dazu, dass man dünner wird.
Das Beste, was man machen kann, ist eigentlich gesünder bzw. weniger kalorienreich futtern.
Oder nicht so viel Dreck nebenbei fressen.
Aber es hilft natürlich schon ein bisschen.
Aber man muss halt auch sagen, man hat viel mehr Hunger.
Also seit ich wieder angefangen habe zu rennen und Fahrrad zu fahren.
Also ich habe ja nie so hundertprozentig aufgehört, aber ich habe die letzten, weiß ich nicht, fünf Monate so über den Winter nicht so viel gemacht.
Und, also, ja.
Also ich habe ein bisschen zugenommen in der Zeit, aber es hielt sich in Grenzen.
Aber, jetzt merke ich schon extrem.
Also jetzt, wo ich wieder angefangen habe, Sport zu machen, habe ich halt auch viel mehr Hunger.
Und man muss ja eh, also ich mache das mittlerweile so, am Anfang habe ich immer gedacht, ey komm, für eine Stunde, eineinhalb Stunden rennen, musst du nichts zu essen mitnehmen.
War aber ein Trugschluss, es geht auch ohne, keine Frage.
Also in dem Tempo, wo ich renne, ich renne ja nicht irgendwie so voll am Limit oder so, in dem Tempo, wo ich renne, muss ich nichts zu essen oder zu trinken mitnehmen, eigentlich, um es durchzuhalten.
Wohlgemerkt, nur um es durchzuhalten.
aber es ist trotzdem nicht verkehrt weil man einfach konstanter rennen kann also ich nehme
mir meistens jetzt irgendeinen riegel mit ich habe so ich wollte euch zu amazon ich habe so
eine 20er pack riegel kaufe ich mir ab und zu bei amazon wie heißen diese dinger die gibt es
ich habe vergessen wie die wiederhersteller heißt es sind immer 20 20 verschiedene sorten
20 pack
sind so bunt die entweder kriegler hat so unterschiedlich
heißen die dinger dann muss man kurz bei mir amazon in der history gucken
und dann nämlich wie immer einen mittlerweile mit und ich mache das dann so amazon riegel
Wenn ich noch Riegel suche, finde ich dann was?
Ah ja, Raw Bite.
Jetzt habe ich es hier, Raw Bite.
Was ist das?
Raw Bite.
So.
Und da hole ich mir so eine...
Ey, die haben auch eine größere Packung.
Aber sowas hier.
In der Richtung.
So eine...
Ich...
Ach nee, das ist, weil ich OS-Update im Hintergrund gemacht habe.
Okay, da ist Firefox verziehen
Ich hab die Hälfte von Firefox im Hintergrund ausgetauscht
Okay, ja dann
Dann ist es okay
So, ich nehme immer so einen Riegel hier mit
Ja, so eine
Mischungspackung
So einen Riegel mit und ich mach das jetzt so
Immer wenn ich die große Runde renne
Da komme ich einmal an einem Bahnübergang vorbei
Dann renne ich über den Bahnübergang
Futter ein Stück von dem Riegel
Dann renne ich weiter
dann kommt so eine kleine Brücke
über den Main
da laufe ich dann drüber
esse den restlichen
Riegel oder das zweite Drittel, je nachdem
und dann geht es irgendwann nochmal
so letztes Drittel von der Runde
geht es dann nochmal die Brücke hoch
da laufe ich meistens den steilen Anstieg und
esse den letzten Drittel
vom Riegel
also ich teile das quasi, ich mache quasi immer so
so halbe Minute, Minute
Pause zwischendurch
Futter, Futter, ein Drittel vom
Riegel und dann
geht's weiter. Und das
hat sich jetzt für mich so rausgestellt,
als ist das deutlich besser,
als komplett durchrennen,
weil man einfach konstanter rennt.
Ja, und das ein bisschen, ein bisschen
Energienachschub
hat.
So.
Muss ich eigentlich mal
rebooten, würde ich sagen, weil
OS-Update, gibt's denn hier
Jetplates-Update?
würdest du diese Abnehm-Spritzen
verwenden? Ne, würde ich nicht.
Kollege auf der Arbeit hat
Mount Jaro oder wie das
heißt, benutzt
zum Abnehmen.
Und er meinte, das hat auch voll viel gebracht.
Weiß wirklich,
weiß nicht, ob mir das so optisch
auf den ersten Blick aufgefallen ist,
aber es nicht.
Und der hat
Verstopfung bekommen davon.
Das Video ist
private was du da geschickt hast
warum ist das private
was jetzt müssen wir mal rauskriegen was ist denn das überhaupt für ein video
gewesen aber google gucken okay was war das für ein video was macht ein it es ist
hat mit einem alu schmelzwerk warum wurde das gelöscht hat der hat der
Arbeitgeber gesagt soll weg oder?
Da ist es doch.
Warum? Das wurde nochmal hochgeladen oder was?
ach und das sind 36 minuten okay ich wollte die firma löschen klingt also
klingt jetzt erst mal nicht so spannend aber wenn ihr das recommended so
möglichst englisch auszudrücken nehmen wir das mal auf ich meine ich habe
letztens alle tabs zugemacht wir haben jede menge tabs was stand da gerade
Frankfurt failed?
Hab ich vergessen.
Was war das? Ich hab es nur so aus dem Augenwinkel
gesehen. Frankfurt failed?
Irgendwo ist Frankfurt
gefailed.
Krieg PewDiePie Videos
empfohlen. Was ist denn hier los?
Stop commenting your code.
Ja, das sehe ich auch so.
Ein guter Code dokumentiert
sich selbst. Und außerdem
sollten die das vielmehr so machen wie ich im stream alle einfach immer fehlerfrei programmieren
dann braucht man auch keine tests oder irgendwelche anderen sachen einfach immer first try alles
richtig machen so wie ich das immer vor mache im stream holst du dir eine 50 90 nee das stimmt ja
das ist so also ich schreibe auch so gut wie keine comments das liegt natürlich daran dass ich guter
immer selbst kommentiert und ich nur guten Code schreibe, logischerweise.
Aber bei mir ist es eher der Fall, also erstens bin ich meistens ein bisschen zu faul dafür.
Ich gebe mir aber Mühe, das Zeug ordentlich zu benennen.
Deswegen würde ich sagen, zum größten Teil dokumentiert es sich selbst, aber die zweite Hälfte ist, ich bin zu faul.
Und das nächste ist, wo Comments tatsächlich sinnvoll sind, ist nicht so sehr dieses, also muss ich jetzt mal kurz zeigen,
weil das habe ich auch total oft bei Azubis schon gesehen
die das dann besonders ordentlich
machen wollen, ja
also
gehen wir mal hiervon aus, jetzt keine Ahnung
Kekkel, ups, wo geht das jetzt auf hier
hier, Kekkel.sh
so, so, so, so
bin, bash, machen wir mal bash
und jetzt sagen wir mal, wir machen jetzt hier irgendwie ein if
ja, if tests
ja, was weiß ich, kekw
äh
equals 1 oder so, ja
und hier haben wir dann unseren tolles
so, und dann gibt's
Leute
die schreiben
check if
keck v command
return code is
1, so
da muss man halt sagen, das ist für den Arsch
das braucht keiner
also ich mein, seriously, jeder der
Bash programmieren kann oder jeder der irgendeine
Programmiersprache programmiert, der weiß was das heißt
Der muss das nicht erklärt kriegen in einem Kommentar oben drüber.
Was viel interessanter ist, warum muss denn Keck W1 ausgeben?
Keck W gleich, du kannst gleich, only, was weiß ich, only if Garagen, Garatentor, Garagentor ist offen, so, irgendwie sowas, ja.
das ist tatsächlich
viel besseres kommend,
dann weißt du nämlich auch, warum das Ganze
gemacht wird. Also das da oben braucht
ehrlich gesagt niemand.
Ja, aber das da unten finde ich
dann schon ganz sinnvoll.
Wenn es was ist, was eine Erklärung braucht.
Ich finde in dem Fall ist nicht
ganz klar, warum keck W denn equal 1
sein muss.
Also das ist sinnvoll.
drüber zu schreiben, was es macht,
nochmal in Englisch, macht eigentlich keinen Sinn,
weil die meisten Programmiersprachen sind
ähnlich genug zu Englisch,
dass man das auch lesen kann,
selbst wenn man die Sprache nicht so perfekt kann.
Wenn man die Sprache gut kann, weiß man eh genau,
was es ist. Außer vielleicht
in C++.
Ich hatte letztens wieder irgendwas
in C++, da habe ich mir auch gedacht,
what the fuck.
Ich komme jetzt aber nicht drauf.
Ach ja, wusstet ihr übrigens, dass
C++...
Egal, ich fange jetzt nicht an.
Wenn ich jetzt anfange,
dann höre ich nicht auf
zu meckern.
So, habe ich jetzt eigentlich rebooted?
Ja.
regex ist ja auch nicht selbsterklärend regex kann man schon also bei einem regex macht es
durchaus sinn was man dann eigentlich vor hat zu matchen oder wenn man da ganz abgedrehte
konstrukte drin verwendet wollen sie das ja dann schön wir sollen sie mal machen sie könnten
vielleicht auch versuchen mal ihre standard library irgendwie halbwegs einheitlich zu machen
machen oder mal vielleicht standard library klassen um sinnvolle methoden erweitern
ich sage nur standard copy if back in surfer alle wenn sich das ausgedacht hat
Ja, wenn ihr mal was ekliges...
Wenn ihr mal was ekliges sehen wollt...
Oh, das ist Copy.
Copy if.
Ja, hier noch viel besser.
Und das ist lesbares C++.
Ich weiß nicht...
Ach, keine Ahnung, was mit den Leuten los ist.
Das stimmt.
Kommentare fliegen auch, also,
wie sagt man, fallen einem oftmals auch auf die Füße.
Wenn du was editierst,
das stimmt nicht mehr, was da oben drüber steht.
Dann ist natürlich Blödsinn.
Ja, das liegt halt daran,
wenn die Leute sich Mühe geben.
Beziehungsweise, ich glaube,
das liegt so ein bisschen daran,
manche, das sollte ich auch machen, mache ich nicht, ja, manche, das habe ich letztens auch in einem Video gehört,
manche sagen, okay, wenn sie was programmieren, dann versuchen sie es einfach so zu programmieren,
dass wenn sie daran denken, in einem halben Jahr müssen sie sich das jetzt selbst nochmal angucken
und verstehen, was sie vor einem halben Jahr gemacht haben, dass sie es dann wieder verstehen.
Und ich glaube, das ist eigentlich ein ganz guter Ansatz, die Sachen so zu programmieren,
dass man quasi vorausschauend für sich selbst in einem halben Jahr das wieder verstehen würde.
Ja, genau, sowas.
Aber noch besser,
wenn das oben irgendeine Konstante ist,
so Buffer Size
und dann schreibst du da drunter hier 512.
Ah ja.
Da gab es auch mal letztens diesen, was war das, einen Blog-Eintrag oder so, wo einer darüber geschrieben hat über Business Enterprise Software in der Entwicklung.
Und die haben gesagt, irgendwann war das Ding so kompliziert und es hatte jeder so wenig Bock daran, was anzupassen,
dass die einfach eine sehr große Schleife reingemacht haben und haben dann quasi jedes Release 0 entfernt an der Schleife.
dass sie sagen konnten
huge performance improvements
dass es so aussieht
als hätten sie da voll viel Gehirnschmalz
reingesteckt und in Wirklichkeit
haben sie eine Null gelöscht und haben es dann gepusht
So, wir müssen ja mal gucken, was diese Woche
auf Shithub so trendet
Trending Repositories nicht today, this week.
Ok, AI Zeug.
Office Documents to Markdown.
Aha, wisst ihr was?
Fragt man sich, warum nicht gleich einen Markdown erstellen?
Weil ich persönlich mag es deutlich lieber, Markdown Dokumente zu erstellen, als in Word
rum zu vorwerfen aber gibt ja gut auf der anderen seite wenn die redmi wenn das eben super big is
business enterprise projekt ist ja und die redmi wird von der marketing abteilung erstellt ist jetzt
falsch die die was weiß ich die beschreibung wird von der marketing abteilung erstellt die
können das natürlich nur in word die verstehen natürlich nicht dass sie das den markt machen
könnten und dann ist vielleicht ganz sinnvoll das hier zu können
das ist für lm training ach so ja wer ja auch wer ja auch keck keck nicht keck
wenn microsoft was anderes als er macht letztens hat unsere it was ist der chef
von der it hat erzählt die hatten irgend so ein komisches fragt mich nicht cloud
presentation wir wollen was verkaufen veranstaltungen da waren leute von
google da aber leute von microsoft da war leute von amazon da und microsoft hat
ihre gesamte vortragszeit dazu benutzt die leute mit ai kam voll zu texten von
dem sie nichts hören wollten klingt das für euch nach microsoft wie
es aktuell ist also für mich schon und google hat tatsächlich hat er gemeint
google hat tatsächlich auch was sinnvolles erzählt so wie das ist
Datenschutzrechtlich, wenn Sachen in Deutschland bleiben müssen
Und sowas, gerade für Finanzdienstleister
Und sonstige Geschichten
Und er hat gesagt, er fand die Google
Den Google Auftritt
So viel besser als den Microsoft Auftritt
Die im Prinzip für jeden Shit irgendwo
AI
Wusstet ihr, dass in Paint AI mittlerweile drin ist?
Habt ihr das eigentlich gesehen? Guck mal
In Paint gibt es mittlerweile einen AI Knopf
Aber nur wenn du eingeloggt bist
Und ich glaube
Sogar in Notepad
gibt es einen AI Knopf
das habe ich mal erklärt
ja, Notepad hat auch AI
kauf dir jetzt den IBM KI Mainframe
auf der Arbeit, ich bin mir nicht sicher
ob
du das ernst meinst oder nicht
hat IBM
einen KI Mainframe
ich meine, zutrauen würde ich denen alles
Es ist echt, wirklich
Oh
Okay
Neuer Mainframe von IBM
Moment, Moment, das ist
Ah, fuck, ich bin ja in Chrome
Sekunde, Sekunde, das geht nicht
Da habe ich ja Werbung, ohne Ende
Okay
Warum ist wirklich nur noch für den Chat hier eigentlich da?
Mainframes gelten als allgemein nicht besonders KI-fähig.
Gelten die das?
Ich hätte eher gesagt, niemand sieht Sinn in KI mit Mainframe.
Aber okay, mit dem neuen Z17 will IBM die Gegenbeweise antreten.
Aha.
Okay, sieht ja von der Optik erstmal ungefähr so aus wie alle anderen.
Mittlerweile ein bisschen, nicht mal ganz so kantig alles,
aber von der Optik her würde ich sagen, typische Mainframe-Optik.
Bei seinem neuen Mainframe setzt KI ganz auf KI-Fähigkeiten.
Da hat auch irgendein...
Ich frage mich halt, ob KI da...
Äh, nicht KI.
Ob IBM da nicht ein bisschen an dem Bedarf der Anwender vorbei entwickelt.
Gibt es wirklich so viele Leute, die sich KI-Gedöns auf dem Mainframe gewünscht haben?
Ich, also...
Ich habe noch nicht einen gehört, der bisher gesagt hat,
hätte ich mal ein bisschen mehr
äh, Maschinen-Learning-Fähigkeiten
KI-Gedöns auf meinem Mainframe
was ist denn
ein Mainframe?
das ist ein fertiges Rack, was du kriegst, bestückt mit
Hardware von IBM
und du musst das kaufen
aber dir gehört das
nie wirklich und du musst für jede
CPU da drin Lizenzgebühren bezahlen
das ist kein
Witz, das ist wirklich so
deswegen gucken die auch immer, dass das
alles schön ausgelastet ist.
Moment, ich habe gerade meine
Bildervorschau verstellt.
Das bewirkt mich jetzt.
Warum sollte man sowas wollen?
Ja, das fragt man sich tatsächlich.
Tatsächlich, ja.
In der Tat, in der Tat fragt man sich das.
das liegt wahrscheinlich daran dass das heute keiner mehr dabei verstanden ist neu anfängt
aber gerade viele finanzdienstleister historisch gesehen sehr viele programme haben die auf auf
dem mainframe entstanden sind irgendwas mit kobold zum beispiel oder vielleicht auch java
und die dinger sind so tief integriert in die wichtigsten kernprozesse wie man das so schön
nennt abläufe dass sich viele nicht trauen den mainframe abzuschaffen die meisten sachen kannst
du heute wahrscheinlich ohne probleme unter linux laufen lassen ich kenne mich mit mainframe
geschichten nicht aus muss ich ehrlich sagen ich habe davon die konsole mal gesehen ich habe da
auch schon mal mit dem fadenkreuz auf was drauf geklickt das war es dann aber auch die konsole
hat so ein komisches Fadenkreuz drauf.
Ich persönlich verstehe nicht,
was es an
Mainframe-Software gibt,
die nicht, warum, also umgedreht,
ich verstehe nicht, warum es Software
gibt, die nur auf einem Mainframe läuft und nicht auf
einem Linux.
Vielleicht kann mir das einer von euch
High-IQ-Mainframe-Leuten erklären.
Ich könnte mir nur vorstellen, dass das irgendeine
Lizensierung, beziehungsweise
Support-Geschichte ist,
dass du halt Software hast,
die mal irgendwann entwickelt wurde mit Cobol Mainframe Gedöns
und irgendwann dann auch mal oder vielleicht Sachen verwendet,
die irgendwie nur supported werden von einem Drittanbieter,
wenn sie halt auf einem zertifizierten Environment laufen
und das einzig zertifizierte Environment ist halt irgendwie IBM Host oder sowas.
Ansonsten kann ich es mir nicht vorstellen,
warum es, also was denn tolles eine Software können muss,
dass sie nur auf einem Mainframe läuft.
wahrscheinlich traut man sich das auch nicht ich kenne das ja ich arbeite ja
meine finanzdienstleister wahrscheinlich traut man sich das auch
nicht anzufassen so nach dem motto das läuft da jetzt seit 50 jahren drauf
seit 1900 keine ahnung 75 oder so läuft das jetzt auf eine mainframe falls da
schon so wahrscheinlich gab es wieder schon das läuft jetzt 50 jahre drauf und
wir trauen uns das nicht woanders drauf laufen zu lassen weil wir nicht 100
prozent sicher sein können ob es dann funktioniert ich glaube das ist
wahrscheinlich der größte der größte grund ich habe aber noch nie einen von
unseren mainframe leuten ich muss übrigens ehrlich sagen der neuen firma
75.000 euro moment moment du bezahlt 75.000 euro aber die gehört immer noch
nicht du musst dann immer noch lizenzgebühren bzw
wir werden das miete bezahlen für deine cpu kurs so einfach kann es ja nicht
sein da hat sich ibm gedacht wir müssen den
Aluhut aber mal hier ganz, ganz, ne?
Wobei, Aluhut ist das Falsche. Unsere
unsere Rechtsabteilung
hat gesagt, so können wir noch den letzten
Cent da rausholen.
Es ist ein bisschen wie, also,
ich weiß nicht. Chat,
wer hat
die beschissensten Lizenzbedingungen?
Wenn wir mal jetzt sagen,
Prodcom oder
Oracle, IBM,
sap winrar da kann ich nichts zu sagen warum warum sind die adobe lizenz
bedingungen so kacke also wenn ihr mich fragt würde ich auch sagen oracle und
zwar aus einem grund also dem den ich bisher mitbekommen habe wo ich wo ich
mir echt an den Kopf greifen musste.
Und zwar,
wenn du Oracle-Gedöns
virtualisiert laufen lassen
möchtest...
Ja, das stimmt.
Ich meine, wenn du schon...
Wisst ihr, ich finde, sobald du
Rechtsberatung
für irgendwelche Lizenzfragen
brauchst, dann stimmt irgendwas
da prinzipiell nicht.
Also wenn du erstmal irgendwelche Anwälte bezahlen musst,
bevor du dir eine Software kaufen kannst,
dann ist irgendwas verkehrt. Aber gut, das ist bei Oracle
so und das ist bei SAP, das ist bei IBM wahrscheinlich auch so.
Aber eine Sache, die ich bei Oracle
mal mitgekriegt habe, in der alten Firma noch, ist,
wenn du Oracle,
sagen wir, was haben die außer Datenbank eigentlich
noch Spannendes?
Wenn du eine
Oracle-Datenbank
laufen lassen willst,
in der VM,
ach stimmt, Java,
ja gut, das verdränge ich immer, dass das ja Java ist.
was er recht und oracle linux haben sie auch stimmt java natürlich aber java ist
mir eigentlich ziemlich egal muss ich sagen oder könnte ich war ja war ist mir
ziemlich ich habe das ewig nicht verwendet aber ja java gehört auch dazu
zumindest was ich mitgekriegt habe von lizenzbedingungen wenn du eine oracle
Datenbank
in der VM laufen lassen willst.
Und man muss auch dazu sagen, im Jahr 2000,
wann das war, was weiß ich, 2020
oder so, war das so wirklich
nix
besonderes
oder nix abwegiges,
eine Oracle Datenbank in der VM laufen zu lassen.
So, und jetzt
stellt euch mal vor, ihr sagt,
okay, wir lassen eine Oracle Datenbank in der VM laufen.
Die VM bekommt
32 GB RAM
und 4 CPU-Kerne zugewiesen.
jetzt ratet mal wie viel cpu kern ihr lizenzgebühren bezahlen müsst für diese
datenbank obwohl er nur vier benutzen könnt ratet mal gut ich hab ich hab das
kann ich könnte nicht wissen wenn es nicht wisst weil ich habe wichtige
informationen weggelassen also ihr habt eine hardware so müsste ich das ein
Genau so viel wie der Host hat. Richtig.
Also ihr habt eine Hardware unten drunter mit 72 CPU-Kernen, aber darauf erstellt ihr bloß eine VM mit 8 CPU-Kernen.
Dann müsst ihr für 72 CPU-Kernen eine Oracle-Datenbank-Lizenz kaufen, nicht nur für die 8 in der VM.
Ja, es gibt eine Oracle Cloud. Hatten die nicht letztens richtig Probleme in der Oracle Cloud Security-mäßig?
War da nicht irgendwas
Hier, Oracle confirms hack
Der letzte Ding, den ich gelesen habe
Man soll sein Passwort ändern oder sowas
Ja, also, wisst ihr
Das ist halt mal total von Arsch
Ihr habt eine Hardware-Kiste
Unten drunter als Virtualisierungshost
Und meistens ist ja
Virtualisierungshardware recht
Beefy, ja, recht fett
Aber die VMs drauf sind ja dann oftmals deutlich realistischer und zwar eher passend zu dem,
was man braucht.
Und das ist halt komplettes Ausschlusskriterium, was man sagt, oder komplettes K.U.-Kriterium,
wenn du sagst, ey, du musst 72 CPU-Lizenzen kaufen für deine Oracle-Datenbank oder Lizenzieren
für 72 CPU-Kerne, wenn du eigentlich nur 4 brauchst.
Ach ja, und jetzt ist der Witz.
Wisst ihr, was man machen kann, um dieses Limit, beziehungsweise Limit ist es ja nicht,
um diese Lizenzgebühren zu umgehen, was man da machen kann.
Also ja, man kann da Hardware kaufen mit nur 8 oder 4 CPU drin, das funktioniert, ja.
Oder die VM auf einem Node laufen lassen, der nur 4 CPU-Kerne hat.
Ich bin mir übrigens gar nicht sicher, muss man Oracle lizenzieren lassen für,
das müsst ihr jetzt wissen, ich weiß es nämlich nicht,
muss man lizenzieren für, wo es theoretisch laufen könnte oder wo es läuft.
weil man könnte ja auch beispielsweise einen esx cluster haben mit einem note der nur für
orgel datenbank ist der handel 8 cpu sat und aber dann andere note mit 72 aber theoretisch könnte
ja die orgel datenbank auf dem mit 72 mitiert werden und dann muss wahrscheinlich musste das
höchste was geht bezahlen weil oracle immer kack lizenz den ganzen cluster ja wahrscheinlich
kann ich mir gut vorstellen
zumindest die
Lösung, laut Oracle
ist es, man soll einfach
die Oracle Virtualisierung verwenden
da gibt es dann
diese Beschränkung komischerweise nicht
also wenn man die Oracle Virtualisierung
verwendet, die keine Sau
ich kenne wirklich niemand, der die
Oracle Virtualisierung, kennt ihr jemand?
also ich kenne das nur für die Leute, die
gesagt haben, okay wir wollen virtuelle Datenbanken
verwenden und machen dann explizit dafür
nur minimal so ein Oracle-Ding.
Nee, nee, nee, nicht Virtualbox.
Es gibt Oracle-Virtual-
Plattform oder wie auch immer das Ding
heißt.
Nee, nicht Virtualbox.
Es gibt
irgendeine Oracle-Virtualisierungs-
Plattform. Keine Sau verwendet die.
Ja.
Ja, zumindest
damit kann man die Lizenzgebühren umgehen
und dann muss man nur noch Lizenzgebühren für die Datenbank
bezahlen, wie viel CPU-Kerne
auch wirklich in der VM durchgereicht
werden oder gemappt sind.
Ob sich das lohnt, weiß ich nicht.
Und jetzt noch was viel besseres.
Ha! Habe ich auch beim alten
Arbeitgeber erlebt.
Wisst ihr, dass
es eine Oracle-Lizenzbedingung gibt
oder gab. Ich weiß nicht, ob es
die noch gibt oder ob ich die richtig verstanden
habe, deswegen hier keine Rechtsberatung
und sowas. Aber meines Wissens
nach gibt es eine Oracle Lizenzbedingung,
die sagt, eine,
wie soll ich das nennen, eine
Mindestsupport-Level-Lizenzvereinbarung.
Also,
wenn du drei verschiedene Oracle-Produkte
verwendest,
und sagen wir mal,
sagen wir mal, ich bin mir bei Oracle
nicht ganz sicher, sagen wir mal, du kaufst
bei dem einen Bronze-Support, bei dem anderen
Silber-Support und bei dem anderen Gold-Support.
So.
Dann gibt es oder gab es
oder glaube ich, gab es
eine Lizenzbedingung, die sagt,
dass alle weiteren
Produkte, die du kaufst,
mindestens so gut
versichert
supportet werden müssen,
wie die höchste
Software, die du hast. Also,
lange Rede, kurzer Sinn, warum wir das gemerkt haben beim alten
Arbeitgeber ist folgendes. Wir haben
irgendwie, ich sag jetzt mal, Silbersupport gehabt
für unsere Oracle. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob das bei denen so heißt.
Silbersupport gehabt für
unsere Oracle-Datenbanken, aber
wir haben Oracle Linux
verwendet auf einigen Servern.
Wisst ihr übrigens, wie
das Oracle Linux heißt? Da keckt
ihr euch auch weg. Das
nennt sich Oracle
Unbreakable Linux.
Was ja dafür bekannt ist,
dass die so unbreakable sind.
Oh, die gibt's nicht mehr.
Oh, die heißt jetzt anders.
Guck mal, ich bin komplett out of date.
Outdated, overrated, she baited bin ich.
Das heißt gar nicht mehr so.
Ha, da waren sie.
Guck zu einer.
Wobei, angeblich tut es das...
Okay, was auch immer.
Zumindest, lange Rede, kurzer Sinn.
Wir haben die Oracle Linux Installation kostenlos verwendet.
Weil Oracle Linux konntest du kostenlos verwenden.
Mal gucken, ob es das überhaupt noch gibt.
Okay, gibt es anscheinend noch.
Also konntest Oracle Linux kostenlos verwenden.
Stellt euch mal vor, ihr habt jetzt 30 Kisten mit Oracle Linux am Laufen, weil kostenlos.
Und dann kauft ihr euch eine Oracle Lizenz für irgendeine Datenbank.
Mit Supportvertrag.
Und da wollten die uns damals ernsthaft erzählen,
Ja, jetzt müsst ihr alle eure Betriebssysteme, die ihr kostenlos bisher verwendet habt, auch mindestens Silbersupport lizenzieren, weil ihr eine Silbersupport Lizenz gekauft habt.
Ihr versteht, was ich meine, oder?
Also du kaufst die eine Sache und musst dann die anderen Sachen mindestens auch so gut absichern.
Ich weiß nicht, wie das ausgegangen ist, aber war schon echt...
Also, ganz ehrlich, deswegen bin ich der Meinung, Oracle hat mit Abstand die beschissensten Lizenzierungsmodelle und Praktiken.
SAP ist wahrscheinlich ähnlich kacke, da kann ich nichts zu sagen.
Ich habe mich noch nie mit SAP-Lizenzierung beschäftigt.
Wahrscheinlich die SAP-Lizenzierung auch grausam.
Ist nicht so, dass der SAP-Chef irgendeinem Fußballverein,
dass dem irgendein Fußballverein gehört?
Da braucht bestimmt auch Geld.
Ich glaube, ich habe das mal irgendwo gelesen,
dass irgendein SAP-Typ war.
Es scheint aber beliebt zu sein, Sportvereine.
Hat nicht Steve Ballmer von Microsoft einen Basketballverein?
Ist das Hoffenheim?
Wie sind denn die so?
Sind die gut oder schlecht gerade?
Ich habe absolut keine Ahnung von Fußball.
Weil wenn die schlecht sind, braucht er wahrscheinlich Kohle,
dass die wieder besser werden.
Max, weil du Mainframes und Kobold angesprochen hattest.
Aktuelle Schnellenausschreibung der Deutschen Rentenversicherung.
Experte.
Expertin.
Warum nicht?
Ah doch, doch, doch.
Wollte gerade sagen hier.
Männlich, weiß, deutsch.
Ach jetzt schreiben sie irgendwie diff.
dass man keine Witze mehr drüber machen kann, dass das ja auch Deutsch heißen könnte.
Das geht, das ist ja, was soll hier, mitgedacht.
Expert in Datenbankentwicklung erstellen, pflegen und warten von Java-Anleihen
sowie Kobol-Programme in Datenbankzugriff.
Ah ja, ich meine, deutsche Rentenversicherung, das wundert mich nicht, dass da gerade mit Kobol läuft.
Das wundert mich nicht.
DiffTag auf, DiffTag zu.
Das müsstest du da eigentlich reinschreiben.
Mal gucken, ob sie das checken in der Bewerbung.
Oder wahrscheinlich senden sie
die Sonderzeichen, die ihre Software nicht verarbeiten kann.
Stellt euch mal vor,
da ist was drin, was aussieht wie HTML.
Das bringt wahrscheinlich komplett das E-Mail-Programm,
was sie da haben, zum Abkacken.
Die haben da wahrscheinlich...
Was hat man in so einer... Bestimmt noch Lotus Notes, oder?
Was meint ihr?
Hat die deutsche Rentenversicherung noch Lotus Notes?
Das kann ich mir, das ist so ein Laden, da kann ich mir das richtig gut vorstellen.
Wie haben die am Outlook?
Ne, Thunderbird haben die nicht.
Thunderbird ist nicht Business Enterprise genug.
Die haben Fax wahrscheinlich.
Wahrscheinlich wird das per Fax ausgedruckt.
Die haben ein Fax Gateway.
Also jede E-Mail, die reinkommt, wird an ein Faxgerät geschickt mit so einer Endlosrolle drin.
Fragst du Outlook auf dem
Ja, dafür brauchen die wahrscheinlich
den Mainframe
Leute, siehste mal, zwei Minuten
und wir haben es schon ergründet im Stream
Es ist doch klar
Was ist eigentlich aus, wo wir gerade dabei sind
Was ist eigentlich aus
E-Post und D-Mail und so
geworden? Gibt es den Kram
überhaupt noch? Hat es jemals irgendwie
Verbreitung gefunden, weil ich hab
einen ehemaligen Kollegen, der hat bei
ich glaub bei D-Mail oder so
mitgemacht, als es neu war
und der war da voll begeistert
von, so das ist die Zukunft
best ever und sowas
gibt's nicht mehr, okay
Jelly4, du machst Cobon und verdienst 50k
wegen irgendwelchen Tarifverträgen, könntest du
das selber, ja
das stimmt voll, übrigens
Tarifverträge
beste ich habe gestern in die in meine ja wie nennt man das personalakte
geguckt digitale personalakte so nenne ich es jetzt mal ich habe festgestellt
ich krieg ab diesem monat sechs prozent mehr geld habe ich auch so doch ja weiß
und das liegt daran weil es einen tarifvertrag gab wie gesagt für mich
gilt ja eigentlich der tarifvertrag nicht aber es gibt einen tarifvertrag für was wahrscheinlich
wahrscheinlich versicherungsgewerbe oder sowas weiß ich gar nicht welcher tarifvertrag das genau
ist guck da auch gar nicht mal nach seitdem ich nicht mehr nach tarifvertrag bezahlt wer aber die
außer tarifverträge kriegen den gleichen zuwachs wie die tarifverträge hat man so entschieden bei
uns und deswegen kriege ich jetzt einfach 6% mehr Geld.
Chancen, ja.
Es macht aber auch Sinn, das hat mir vor einer Weile mein Chef mal erklärt, das macht auch
Sinn, die haben gesagt, die Außertarifverträge kriegen immer den gleichen Zuwachs wie die
Tarifverträge, weil sonst würdest du ja irgendwann von den Tarifverträgen überholt
werden, macht ja schon Sinn.
Stellt euch mal vor, ihr seid, jetzt habt ihr einen außertariflichen Vertrag und in
zehn Jahren habt ihr nicht eine Erhöhung
bekommen und die Tarifverträge ziehen
an euch vorbei.
Also macht irgendwie Sinn.
Deswegen gab es einfach random 6%
mehr Geld.
Will ich mich jetzt mal nicht beschweren
drüber.
Und es gab sogar eine
Bonuszahlung, weil es immer im April eine
Bonuszahlung gibt und
wenn ich mir angucke, was ich da schon wieder
an Steuern bezahlen muss,
will ich es mir schon wieder gar nicht so genau angucken.
Wenn ich schon sehe,
dass da fast die Hälfte wieder an Steuern weggeht.
Von dem, was oben steht.
Zu dem, was unten an der Überweisung rauskommt.
So krass ist es bei mir auch nicht.
Ich arbeite ja nur Teilzeit.
Wenn ich 100% arbeiten würde,
mit Rufbereitschaft und allem dabei,
dann wäre das wirklich sehr ordentlich.
Zum Thema in die Schweiz kommen.
Letztes Jahr hat einer bei uns aufgehört.
Und der ist in die Schweiz gezogen.
Und ich meine, bei uns gibt es schon viel Kohle.
Aber in der Schweiz gab es wahrscheinlich noch mehr Kohle.
Und wahrscheinlich auch angenehmere Umstände drumherum.
Außer Tarif nicht mitstreiken.
Also ehrlich gesagt, ich gehe davon aus, dass du schon mitstreiken darfst.
Du darfst da schon mitmachen.
Es wird wahrscheinlich keiner sagen, du darfst da nicht hinkommen.
Aber du kriegst wahrscheinlich Probleme mit deinem Arbeitgeber, wenn du da hingehst.
Also die werden dich nicht rausschmeißen dort, wenn du hingehst.
Wenn du sagst, ich will mitstreiten, sagen die, mach ruhig mit.
Aber du wirst wahrscheinlich Probleme bekommen, weil du unentschuldigt abwesend bist.
Kann auch nach hinten losgehen, ja gut.
hast du eigentlich die stürze um gesundheitszustände in europa gesehen
drei viertel haben wohl gesundheitliche probleme vor allem richtung burnout ja
das gab es bei golem oder
Oder?
Ja.
Äh.
Ähm.
Gab's da nicht irgendeine Übersicht?
Hier.
Gesunder dem Job.
IT-Lern geht's immer schlechter.
Naja.
Also ich hab euch ja nicht so erzählt.
Ich hatte keinen Burnout oder sowas.
Ja.
Aber.
Ähm.
Ich hab euch ja nicht erzählt.
warum ich die letzten Monate wenig gestreamt habe
oder keine Videos gemacht habe.
Aber so ganz topfit war ich auch nicht.
Sonst hätte ich ja gestreamt.
Ja, nicht mehr ganz dicht sind ITler in der Regel schon.
Aber es ist die Frage,
ob es ihnen selbst zu schaffen macht oder nicht.
Also man kann einen Schaden haben,
aber selbst vollkommen happy sein damit.
Hier geht es ja darum, einen Schaden zu haben
und selbst nicht happy zu sein damit.
Ja.
Oh, drei Seiten.
Warum uns IT-Learn schlecht geht.
Okay, das müssen wir uns jetzt tatsächlich mal angucken.
Bei vielen der befragten IT-Angestellten wirkt sich die Situation des Unternehmens negativ auf ihr Befinden aus.
Gut, kann ich mir vorstellen, wenn der Laden immer kurz vor der Pleite ist und du immer erzählt kriegst,
nächsten Monat machen wir dicht.
Oder wenn du bei MeinFactory warst oder so, dann...
Ich renne nicht jeden Tag 15 Kilometer, oder?
Was war da gerade, Chat?
Ne, ne.
Ich renne ab und zu mal 15 Kilometer.
Ich mache einmal die Woche einen Long Run.
Wie man das so cool nennt.
Chat, ich habe vergessen.
Wo ist jetzt...
Oh, ne.
Hier.
jeweils 34 prozent fühlen sich durch die angespannte lage im unternehmen belastet
war durch die eine schlechte auftragslage aufgrund von führungswechsel
oder firmenübernahmen 36 prozent klagen wird zu gering oder gar keine boni
übrigens ich habe das erfahren ich sagte es ja hier anonym ich wurde ja versucht
mehrfach abzuwerben bevor ich dann meinen job gewechselt
habe im April
und einer
der Unternehmen, die mich
versucht haben abzuwärmen, beziehungsweise derjenige,
der mich dort versucht hat abzuwärmen,
der wurde jetzt raus,
wurde jetzt gefeuert, habe ich gehört
um drei Ecken, wegen Arbeitszeitbetrug.
Weil ich hier gerade Führungskräftewechsel
lese. Das ist auch scheiße, überlegt euch mal.
Ihr seid in einem Team, alles läuft gut
und euer Chef wird wegen Arbeitszeitbetrug rausgeschmissen.
Das ist eine Kack-Situation für alle, oder?
Also was er gemacht hat, weiß ich nicht.
Ja, keine Ahnung.
Ob das gerechtfertigt ist oder war, weiß ich auch nicht.
Manchmal sind solche Sachen ja auch Vorwand für andere Sachen.
Wie läuft es mit deinem Fahrrad?
Da waren wir jetzt letztes Mal...
Ende...
Nee, nee, nicht letztes Jahr.
Vorletztes Jahr.
Ende 2023 hat mich einer umgefahren an der Ausfahrt.
Das hat sich mittlerweile alles erledigt.
Also Verletzungen hatte ich ja eh keine.
Ein bisschen Abschürfung.
Aber das Geld ist mittlerweile auch da.
Die haben da irgendwie ein Dreivierteljahr oder so gebraucht.
Ein halbes Jahr gebraucht von der Versicherung,
bis sie alles bezahlt haben.
Ich war ja extra noch beim Anwalt.
Also ich war, was heißt noch?
Ich war direkt beim Anwalt.
Und das hat sich trotzdem ewig hingezogen.
Du warst regelmäßig Fahrradfahren.
Ja, ich war jetzt ein bisschen weniger Fahrradfahren.
Also ich war letzten Sonntag, war ich 52 Kilometer Frankfurt und zurück.
Am Mainradweg bin ich lang gefahren.
der zu großen Teilen auch neu, wie nennt man das, geteert wurde, neu gemacht.
Viele Stellen sind aber immer noch eklig mit Wurzel durchzogen.
Und ich muss sagen, ich bin das nicht mehr gewöhnt.
Ich bin 52 Kilometer gefahren.
Das ist, ich will nicht sagen, dass das sonst eine Länge ist,
wo ich sage, das mache ich easy so nach dem Aufstehen mal kurz vor der Arbeit.
Aber 52 Kilometer habe ich sonst keine Probleme mit.
Leute, ich habe auf dem letzten Loch gepfiffen, als ich heimgekommen bin.
Ich habe das Ganze ja getrackt mit meinem Garmin-Fahrradcomputer und der meinte, dass meine Body-Battery, also quasi so was ich so an Füllung in mir drinne habe, dass der nach zwei Dritteln auf 1% war.
Das heißt, ich bin das letzte Drittel mit leerer Body-Battery gefahren.
Und das habe ich gemerkt, ey. Das habe ich richtig gemerkt.
Das letzte Drittel hat sich so gezogen.
Aber wir dürfen nicht vergessen, ein Drittel sind irgendwie 16, 17 Kilometer oder so noch.
Und, Leute, ich hatte die letzten 15 Kilometer, hatte ich eine Durchschnittswatt von, glaube ich, 98.
So, das ist so, 98, das ist so, was die Oma, na gut, nee, die Oma hat nicht ganz so viel.
was der Opa hat,
wenn er sonntags morgens Brötchen holen
fährt und schnell wieder heim will.
Ungefähr.
So das.
Und wenn ich mehr,
wenn ich härter
reingetreten hab, so weißt du was ich,
so ab 120 Watt haben übelst
meine Oberschenkel wehgetan, das letzte Drittel.
Ich bin das überhaupt nicht mehr, davor ging's,
davor war eigentlich so normal,
wie immer.
ich darf auch nicht vergessen, ich bin 8 Kilometer
gerannt den Tag vorher,
am gleichen Tag, vormittags.
Nachmittags bin ich dann die 52 Kilometer
nach Frankfurt gefahren und zurück.
Also insgesamt 52 Kilometer.
Und
das letzte Drittel habe ich richtig gemerkt.
Also ich hatte richtig Probleme,
ich konnte nicht mal richtig die Treppe hochgehen.
Gestern ging es,
gestern konnte ich nicht mal richtig die Treppe runtergehen,
nach 15 Kilometer rennen.
Da habe ich beim Treppe runterlaufen
gemerkt. Und Leute, ich hab, ich weiß nicht,
was es ist. Ich will euch da jetzt auch kein Foto von machen.
Ich will euch nicht ekeln oder sowas.
Ich hab, ich muss mal kurz mein...
Mal hier unter
meinen Socken gucken. Ich hab ne Blase
am Fuß. Ich hatte noch nie...
Ich bin es einfach nicht mehr
gewöhnt, ja. Ich hab jetzt die letzten 4-5
Monate nicht so viel gemacht. Und es ist
bestimmt schon ein halbes Jahr her, dass ich
15 Kilometer am Stück gerannt bin.
Na, nicht ganz. Das war 5 Monate
her. Ich hab ne Blase, Leute,
am fuß hier so am linken wo ist das ballen oder so eine blase die ist rot und die ist bestimmt
zwei zentimeter lang ich wusste gar nicht die ist also dies zwei zentimeter lang und ein zentimeter
hoch das ist ein richtig großes ei was ich nehme am fuß habe seit gestern vom rennen ich habe noch
ich hatte noch nie eine so große blase am fuß naja zumindest muss ich das nächste mal an meinen
fuß auch so ein bisschen weiß gar nicht was das ist ich habe so einen stick bei amazon gekauft
und ich weiß nicht ob das kopium ist und das eigentlich nur einbildung ist aber ich bilde
mir eines funktioniert. Hier, Bodystick.
Also, hört sich perverse
an, als es ist. Bodykleid.
Ja. Ich hab keine Ahnung,
was das genau ist. Ob da Teflon oder
irgendein...
MonkaS. Ich hab schon gedacht, Mist.
Monka Tossbill aufgemacht, Alter.
Ja. So. Da kann man sich mit
einschmieren.
Und dann kleidet
die Bekleidung.
Ohne zu reiben.
Und das mache ich immer auf der Brust oben, weil dort ab 10 Kilometer aufwärts halt einfach das Trikot ziemlich reibt.
Das funktioniert richtig gut.
Ja, Pflaster habe ich auch, aber ich finde Pflaster unangenehmer.
Ich finde Pflaster unangenehmer.
Und das funktioniert richtig gut.
ich habe überhaupt keine Reibung
mehr hier so auf der Brust oder sonst was,
seitdem ich das verwende vor längeren
Renntouren. Das nächste Mal
mache ich mir das neben auch an Fuß dran.
Ne, ich weiß nicht, ob da Teflon oder
irgendwas dran...
Das Bild, das könnte,
wenn es was anderes wäre und auf der anderen Seite,
könntest du dir auch denken, boah, KS, Alter.
Imstrieben.
Ja, ich habe keine Ahnung, was da drin ist, aus was das besteht, aber es ist 100% vegan.
Das ist natürlich sehr wichtig für mich.
Ich habe da schon immer mal das Bedürfnis gehabt, reinzubeißen.
Ohne, mal ganz davon abgesehen, ich wäre nie im Leben drauf gekommen, dass so ein Stick zum Einreiben irgendwas mit veganen und Tierversuchen oder so zu tun hätte.
Aber gut, dass es ohne Tierversuche und 100% vegan ist.
also ich habe keine ahnung auf aus was das besteht zumindest das funktioniert bei mir
eigentlich ganz gut ja das muss ich mir das nächste mal wohl auch auf den fuß schmieren
dass ich nicht mehr so eine blase krieg wenn ich wenn ich jetzt ein paar mal die große runde wieder
gerannt bin dann ist es kein problem dann habe ich ein bisschen hornhaut am fuß und dann geht
das aber jetzt also wirklich das ist echt große blase so aber eigentlich wollten wir uns ja
angucken warum ITler, warum es ITlern schlecht geht. Genau also Führungswechsel,
Firmenübernahme, 36 Prozent klagen über zu geringe oder gar keine Boni.
Ja, kann man auch immer drüber klagen, ist nie verkehrt. Prinzipiell ist der Bonus
immer zu gering. Wenn man sich über was beschweren will, kann man sich
immer darüber beschweren, dass der Bonus zu gering ist. Wobei ich ehrlich sagen muss,
ich beschwere mich nicht darüber, dass der Bonus zu gering ist. Ich finde eh schon,
dass das wir generell für das was wir machen eigentlich viel zu viel geld
kriegen gemessen an dem was man so durchschnittlich verdient so gemessen an
dem für halte ich für gerechtfertigt was wir was wir kriegen würde ich
eigentlich sagen ja ist es ja aber wenn man es mal an dem gesamtschnitt sieht ja
und auch was da für andere berufe drin sind dann nicht aber insgesamt würde
schon sagen ist das gerechtfertigt
Aber ich beklage mich nicht, dass der Bonus zu gering ist oder sowas.
Das ist alles in Ordnung.
Bei Belastungsfaktoren am Arbeitsplatz zeigt sich ein hoher Termindruck.
Stress und Hektik im eigenen Arbeitsbereich.
Ja, das kann ich mir gut vorstellen.
Das ist bei uns nicht anders.
Unklare Zielvorgaben.
Aber ja, irgendwie ist das glaube ich überall so.
Wo du dir denkst, ja was wollt ihr denn jetzt eigentlich genau?
Ja, so, ja, aber wie denn?
Wie, erzähl mal, wie stellst du es dir genau vor?
Ah
Da ist einfach, wie nennt man es so schön?
Die User-Story muss noch nachgeschärft werden
Und mangelnde Wertschätzung
Ja, okay, das kann ich mir vorstellen
Gerade wenn du im Support
Arbeitest
dürfte das wahrscheinlich der Haupt-Painpoint, um es handy zu nennen, sein.
Die mangelnde Wertschätzung.
Also ich würde um Leben nicht im Support anfangen.
Ehemaliger Kollege von mir, der jetzt auch dort arbeitet, wo ich arbeite,
der hat ja vorher im Support gearbeitet.
Also gleiche Firma wie ich früher, plus er im Support und ich nicht im Support.
Und der macht jetzt das gleiche wie ich in der Firma, wo ich jetzt auch arbeite.
aber nicht mehr Support.
Und ich gehe davon aus,
dass mangelnde Wertschätzung auch eines seiner größten Punkte war,
die ihm da auf den Sack gegangen sind.
Plus, dass generell die Probleme vom alten Arbeitgeber,
das hat mir immer viel versprochen, wurde nichts gehalten,
aber das ist was anderes.
IT ist für viele deutsche Unternehmen immer noch das lästigste,
was sie umgehen.
Ja, die sind ja auch ziemlich bescheuert.
Also, man sieht ja auch, dass es anders geht.
was ja auch ziemlich bescheid ist weil die können einfach sonst nichts machen
das muss dann auch mal viele verstehen dass die meisten unternehmen mit der it nicht direkt ihr
geld verdienen ja wir sind nicht alle cloud anbieter aber dass durch die it ist überhaupt
erst möglich ist in der heutigen zeit so viel kohle zu schärfeln wie sie machen
das muss man mit ist deswegen geht diese sache mit kost alles nur geld ist wenn man mal sieht
dass es ohne halt überhaupt alles andere nicht das abliefern könnte was es abliefert ist das
ist eine bescheuerte einstellung aber ja kann ich dir recht denken sicherlich immer noch viele
fast jeder dritte itler ist von burnout betroffen besorgt ist die zahl an burn out der burnout fälle
unter den befragten titel an fast ein drittel gab anders im vergangenen jahr ein oder mehrere team
und er gibt es bei uns auch welche das ist deutlich mehr als ja okay 13 prozent
ist ganz schön viele
wenig überraschend arbeiten als healer in kleinen unternehmen offenbar so lang
weiter bis sie nicht mehr können ja gut die stories die man auf reddit teilweise liest so
nach dem motto chef steht vor der tür oder war das nicht so dass bei tesla der der chef geklingelt
hat wenn die leute krank waren daheim um zu gucken ob er wirklich daheim ist und krank ich glaube das
war tesla und wenn es nicht tesla war es würde gut zu tesla passen ja okay war tesla
In der Zukunft erwarten sie, dass es eher besser als schlechter wird.
Es gibt auch ein paar gute Nachrichten, okay.
Schauen wir mal, was gute Nachrichten sind.
Außer, dass ich Werbung habe.
Was ist der Grund, warum du nicht mehr auf den Altenladen gehst?
diese Sache mit Return to Office und sowas ist, gerade seit da wohl der Abteilungsleiter nochmal gewechselt hat,
die haben eh gefühlt eine sehr kurze Halbwertszeit bei meinem alten Arbeitgeber für Abteilungsleiter,
so nach dem Motto, alle 1-2 Jahre neuer, weil der Alte keinen Bock mehr hat.
Und der neue Abteilungsleiter, der muss dafür bekannt sein, dass er öfters mal ausflippt.
Ich kenne den noch von früher, da war er bloß noch kein Abteilungsleiter.
Ja, und jetzt haben mir zwei Leute erzählt, dass der jetzt Abteilungsleiter ist.
Und wisst ihr was, ich glaube, das habe ich euch im Stream schon mal erzählt.
Wisst ihr, was der als eines einer ersten Amtshandlungen gemacht hat?
Weil er bekannt dafür ist, dass er gerne mal ausflippt.
Der hat ein Dokument rumgeschickt per E-Mail, wie man mit ihm zusammen, genau, so eine Guide-Line,
Der hat Guides rumgeschickt, wie man mit ihm zusammenarbeiten kann, ohne dass er ausflippt.
Da muss man sich doch schon mal fragen, haben die wirklich die richtige Position mit der richtigen Person besetzt?
Das ist kein Witz übrigens, ja. Hört sich jetzt lustig an, aber das ist kein Witz.
Also da muss ich wirklich sagen, das ist ein Unterschied wie Tag und Nacht zwischen dem alten Laden, wo ich gearbeitet habe und dem neuen.
Bei dem neuen habe ich wirklich den Eindruck, dort werden Leute Führungskraft, die sich eignen dafür, Führungskraft zu werden.
Ich kann es sowohl auf Teamleiterebene als auch auf Abteilungsleiterebene sehen bei meinem jetzigen Arbeitgeber, wie viel besser das funktioniert und wie viel angenehmer die Zusammenarbeit mit den Leuten ist als bei meinem alten Arbeitgeber.
also da haben die wirklich leute die das ist nicht so wie also beim alten arbeitgeber was
so teamleiter bist du geworden wenn du wenn jemand gesucht haben du warst bei drei nicht
auf dem baum wenn du beim 3 wenn du bei drei nicht auf den bäumen warst wurdest du zum
teamleiter ob du willst oder nicht so und dementsprechend und geeignet waren die leute
auch dafür und leute die sich da dann gefühlt als besonders geeignet ungeeignet herausgestellt haben
die wurden dann irgendwann auch Abteilungsleiter und haben es dann aber auch nicht lange gemacht, so war das bei meinem alten Arbeitgeber.
Bei meinem neuen Arbeitgeber habe ich tatsächlich eher den Eindruck, dass das eine Karriereoption ist, die von etwas längerer Hand vorbereitet wird,
also du kannst sagen, ich möchte gerne Teamleiter werden, ich möchte mich in die Richtung entwickeln,
dann kannst du auch schon mal ein paar Übungskurse machen, lange bevor du die Möglichkeit hast, überhaupt Teamleiter zu werden,
ob das überhaupt was für dich ist, das heißt, du wirst da gar nicht so ins kalte Wasser geschmissen,
Du hast eine Übergangszeit, wo der alte Teamleiter noch am Start ist und der neue quasi noch am Start.
Also das ist viel besser und viel mehr durchdacht und dementsprechend habe ich auch den Eindruck,
die sind einfach besser, die Führungskräfte bei meinem neuen Arbeitgeber, als bei meinem alten.
Viel besser.
Es wirkt fast so, als hat sich da jemand Gedanken drüber gemacht.
Office-Zwang als Kündigungsgrund wollten wir mal lesen.
Da gab man Forderungen von SAP-Kundigungen.
Ja gut.
Der hat sich ja da hervorgetan.
In der Wahrnehmung unserer Befragten wird sie vom Homeoffice am stärksten beeinflusst und von IT-Lehnen, die auf T-Mobile-Arbeit deutlich besser eingestellt sind, von Angestellten, die auf...
Ja gut, einmal im Homeoffice wollen viele IT-Lehne diese Vorteile nicht mehr hergeben und sind eher bereit zu kündigen, sollte eine dauerhafte Rückkehr ins...
Ja, verstehe ich auch. Wisst ihr, ganz ehrlich, es ist und das verstehen, glaube ich, viele irgendwie Ultra-Business-Enterprise-Karriere-Crinder und...
Führungskräfte nicht. Es ist gar nicht so
sehr die Arbeit im Büro,
die die Leute abschreckt.
Das ist es gar nicht.
Es ist alles, was damit zusammenhängt.
Also die Noob-
Führungskräfte, die denken sich ja,
die Leute wollen nicht im Büro sein, weil
sie dann chillen können.
Ich will nicht ausschließen, dass das
durchaus vorkommt bei vielen Leuten, ja, aber
ich würde sagen, die
meisten Leute schaffen daheim mindestens
genau das gleiche, was sie im Büro schaffen würden.
Und ja, für viele, die denken nur an Büro und daheim. In Wirklichkeit, das Schlimmste an ins Büro fahren, ist das Fahren. Ist das mit der Welt sich auseinandersetzen müssen beim Hin- und Zurückweg. Das ist das eigentliche Problem.
Wenn ich morgens aufstehen könnte, ja, in irgendeinen Beamer steigen und ich würde im Büro spawnen, dann wäre das was anderes.
Dann wäre das ein bisschen wie bei, wie heißt diese Serie? Severance, Severance, genau. Hat das jemand geguckt? Severance?
Ich spoilere nicht, nur für den Fall der Fälle, dass ihr das gucken wollt, ja.
Ich bin gerade ungefähr bei der Hälfte der zweiten Staffel
Das ist ja auch so ein bisschen
Als könnte man sich ins Büro rein und raus bieben
Nur dass man vom restlichen Leben
Außerhalb vom Büro nichts mitkriegt
Es passiert fast gar nichts
Das stimmt auch wieder
Außer Ziegen im Büro
Ich sag ja auch absichtlich
mindestens das schaffen,
was sie im Büro schaffen.
Ich schaffe daheim auch mehr als im Büro.
Allein schon, weil du nicht das ganze
Geschwätze hast, das Abgelenke,
oh, jetzt ist es 12.30 Uhr, jetzt ist es
11.30 Uhr, die Kantine macht bald auf.
Das ist alles.
Im Büro kriege ich deutlich weniger geschafft.
Wir sagen ja auch immer, ah, jetzt ist,
morgen ist der Bürotag, da tut sich doch eh nichts.
Keine Spoiler, Leute.
ja aber ich verstehe dass es für viele leute den kündigungsgrund ist zu sagen
wenn ich die möglichkeit habe remote zu arbeiten und jetzt mal die ganzen
vorteile gesehen habe dann will ich das auch weitermachen und wenn man
arbeitgeber da jetzt komplett zurück rudert dann suche ich mir was an das
kann ich kann ich nachvollziehen das war bei mir auch eines der größeren gründe
also neben den anderen problemen die es da so gab dass ich beim alten arbeitgeber gesagt habe ich
habe keinen bock mehr drauf und man muss sagen es steht ja matrix danke für den sap max danke
für den sap und das war's danke für die subs leute ich habe das beim alten arbeitgeber gemerkt die
haben auch rückzieher gemacht davon ja und ich habe gesehen wie gut das funktioniert das war
eines meiner Hauptgründe, warum ich gesagt habe zu wechseln, warum ich gesagt habe, ich will da eigentlich weg.
Und ich muss sagen, bei meinem neuen Arbeitgeber, es steht nicht in meinem Arbeitsvertrag drin,
direkt schwarz auf weiß mit Homeoffice-Regelung, aber es gibt eine betriebsweit geltende Vereinbarung mit dem Betriebsrat
und es halten sich auch alle dran und man muss dazu sagen, die machen das richtig, es halten alle Seiten den Ball flach.
Also, Führungskräfte und IT-Leitung und sowas kommen jetzt nicht an mit, wir müssen die Leute zur Rückkehr ins Büro zwingen und machen laufend Pflichtanwesenheitstermine.
Umgedreht ist es aber auch nicht so, dass die Leute sagen, wir bestehen jetzt darauf, dass ich mindestens so, an dem Tag komme ich nicht, obwohl da ein wichtiger Termin ist.
Die machen das richtig, das halten alle beide Seiten den Ball flach.
die eine Seite sagt, okay
wir müssen nicht unbedingt jede
Veranstaltung irgendwie verpflichtend machen
und nicht jede Anstaltung verpflichtend fortmachen
und die andere Seite sagt, ey, wenn es mal was
wichtiges ist vor Ort und ich war die Woche schon
da, ich komme auch zweimal die Woche ins Beruf, ist auch
kein Problem, aber im Großen und
Ganzen ist es bei uns so
dass wir einen Tag die Woche vor Ort sind
und
man könnte jetzt ja sagen, eigentlich ist es
ja unfair, bei vier Tage
Woche auch einen Tag, bei fünf Tage Woche
ein Tag, aber ganz ehrlich, ist mir scheißegal.
Ein Tag die Woche bin ich voll und ganz
fein damit.
Und finde ich auch eigentlich ganz gut, weil
an dem Tag passiert gar nichts. Wirklich null
passiert bei uns an dem Tag, weil an dem Tag ist auch
Teamrunde, Gruppenrunde
und sonstiges Gemiete.
Der vor Ort Anwesenheitstag
bei uns, ist meistens Mittwoch,
ist wirklich von
morgens bis
mittags durchgemietet.
Zwischenzeitlich wird das Ganze nur
unterbrochen von, ach, Gruppenrunde
ist jetzt vorbei, wir können ja auch in die Kantine
gehen.
Meistens gehe ich nicht mit in die Kantine, weil ich mir immer nicht
sicher bin, wie gut ich das vertrage in der Kantine.
Und ich brauche
dann zwischen dem ganzen Gemiete auch mal meine Ruhe.
Ich gehe dann meistens einfach zum
Bäcker, hole mir zwei, drei Sachen und
setze mich, wenn alle in der Kantine sind, vor den Rechner
und
mache das, was ich am liebsten mache,
nämlich einfach in schlechter Haltung vor dem Computer sitzen.
Könnt ihr euch das
vorstellen? Ich glaube,
Viele so super, wie soll man sagen, kommunikative Leute können sich das überhaupt nicht vorstellen,
dass man nach einem Tag Meeting gar keinen Bock mehr hat, auch noch zusammen in die Kantine zu gehen.
Bei mir ist es so, ich bin mir erstens nicht sicher, wie gut ich es vertrage in der Kantine
und zweitens will ich nach halbem Tag Gemiete einfach auch mal 45 Minuten meine Ruhe haben.
Kann man das nachvollziehen?
Ich will einfach mal 40 Minuten, dann ist eh keiner da im Büro, weil die alle in der Kantine hocken.
Ich gehe mir beim Bäcker zwei, drei Brötchen holen, futter das in Ruhe vorm Computer.
Das ist für mich, obwohl ich am Computer sitze und da auch Sachen für die Arbeit mache, zum größten Teil zumindest,
ich gucke auch manchmal ein bisschen auf Reddit rum, wenn ich Mittagspause habe,
aber zum größten Teil mache ich da tatsächlich was für die Arbeit.
Also in der Mittagspause.
Das ist für mich erholsamer, als nochmal mit allen in der Kantine zu hocken,
nachdem ich schon den ganzen Tag gemietet habe und den restlichen Tag noch miete.
Homeoffice wollen sie nicht mehr aufgeben
Mehr Unterstützung
So, jetzt muss ich nochmal Chat
Kurz was beantworten, da gab es nämlich ein paar Sachen
Wie viele
Mitarbeiter circa sind bei euch in der Firma?
Ich weiß es nicht, aber ich würde sagen
Wir sind weltweit
Das ist eine Versicherung
Wir sind weltweit aktiv
Tausende, keine Ahnung
Ich kann es dir gar nicht sagen, wie viele es genau sind
Also ich kann es nur sagen, wie es bei uns im Team ist.
Ich habe nicht das Gefühl, dass irgendjemand...
Jetzt könnt ihr natürlich sagen, Max, das musst du jetzt sagen, weil es könnte ja auch dein Chef zugucken.
Ja, whatever.
Aber ich habe nicht das Gefühl, dass es bei uns einer großartig ausnutzt.
Ich habe sogar gesehen, die Leute melden sich an und ab, wenn sie irgendwie, was weiß ich, was einkaufen gehen oder so.
und da habe ich in der alten Firma erlebt, dass Leute
wirklich so da, also in der alten Firma
habe ich erlebt, dass das Leute
ausgenutzt haben, so nach dem Motto
ich melde mich an, setze mich dann in Zug und habe das
Laptop Fall der Fälle
dabei und sowas
ich habe mich auch letzte Woche, letzte Woche
musste ich mit meiner Mutter
zum Arzt, als Begleitung
und da habe ich das so gelegt
dass ich, also was heißt
Ich habe das nicht so gelegt, das stimmt nicht. Das hat so gelegen, die konnten das ja nicht aussuchen. Ich hatte zwei Meetings in der Zeit. Ich hatte ein Projekt, Daily Stand-Up Scrum Meeting und unsere Gruppenrunde.
und das sind halt zwei Meetings, die kann ich ohne Probleme auch unterwegs machen.
Da habe ich halt ausgestochen, als wir da hingegangen sind,
als das erste Meeting angefangen hat, habe ich eingestochen,
habe da 25 Minuten oder so daily gemietet,
ich habe ZZ mitgenommen, Handy mitgenommen, fertig.
Dann habe ich mich dort auf den Parkplatz gesetzt, habe halt gemietet.
Dann habe ich wieder ausgestochen und als unsere Teamrunde angefangen hat, habe ich wieder eingestochen für die Zeit der Teamrunde.
Dann habe ich wieder ausgestochen.
Und als ich daheim am Rechner war, habe ich wieder eingestochen.
Also ich finde, solche Vereinbarungen leben irgendwie auch davon, dass sich beide Seiten etwas entgegenkommend, nenne ich es mal, dran halten.
Also der Chef muss euch nicht auf den Sack gehen, aber ihr solltet es auch nicht übertrieben ausnutzen.
Wenn unterm Strich gesehen, dass bei plus minus null rauskommt, dann ist alles gut.
Wenn jetzt eine Seite deutlich mehr Vorteile hat oder ich sag mal, deutlich mehr Vorteile
daraus ziehen will als die andere, dann geht das wahrscheinlich auf Dauer nicht gut.
Doch, ich hab tatsächlich was erzählt. Ich wusste nicht alles, weil ich mein Textdokument
nicht dabei hat. Doch, doch.
Ich hab sogar was erzählt.
Ich überlege gerade,
was das für ein Tag war.
Ach ja.
Ich glaube, ich hab erzählt,
dass es eine blöde Idee ist.
Irgendwas mit
Namespaces war.
Namespaces?
Genau.
Ich habe erzählt, dass es eine blöde Idee ist, defaultmäßig einen Namespace zu annotaten, sodass alle Workloads da drin einen SQL-Proxy injected kriegen und dort einen Pod, den man eigentlich nur ab und zu braucht, dauerhaft mit einer Endlosschleife laufen zu lassen, nur dass es Entwickler einfacher haben, sich drauf rein zu exekuten, falls man das jetzt irgendwie verstanden hat.
Also die Idee war folgendes, das ist eigentlich total abgedreht, in unserer Entwicklungsumgebung, da gibt es ein paar Installationen, im Kubernetes Cluster gibt es ein paar Namespaces und ein paar Installationen von der gleichen Anwendung für unsere Entwickler, dass sie da halt parallel dran entwickeln können.
So, jetzt müssen die manchmal die Datenbank droppen, damit sie fresh starten können und deployen können und alles. So, daraufhin hatten wir ursprünglich eigentlich gesagt, ist doch ganz easy, führt einfach hier so ein PSQL-Kommando aus, ja, wir geben euch hier einen Container, da ist ein PSQL drin, verbindet euch rein, führt das PSQL aus, danach ist die Datenbank leer.
Dann müsst ihr bei uns nicht anrufen, dann müssen wir uns keine Workflows ausdenken oder sonst was. Hört es einfach aus und gut ist. Das war für die aber am Anfang zu kompliziert. Du jebaitest mich, oder? Jebaited, richtig jebaited. Das war am Anfang für die zu kompliziert.
Dann sind sie irgendwann darauf übergegangen, sie haben einen Container genommen von uns, wo das Postgres-Command-Line-Tool mit drin ist und haben das Startup-Command von diesem Container, also der Container hatte kein Startup-Command oder kein Entry-Point, weil der dafür gedacht ist, interaktiv ab und zu mal für Admin-Sachen ausgeführt zu werden und dann wieder gelöscht zu werden.
Da haben die eine Endlosschleife reingepatcht, ja, while true sleep 9000 als Startup-Command, dass der Container sich nicht mehr beendet, dass sie danach nicht kubectl run, sondern kubectl execute machen können und immer wieder in den gleichlaufenden Container rein können.
So, also so eine Art Debug-Container.
So, und irgendwie haben wir dann gesagt, das ist doch eigentlich voll durch die Brust ins Auge.
warum startet ihr nicht einfach
CubeCTL Run den Container nur wenn ihr
ihn braucht und das in einem Namespace
wo es eben automatisch
schon eine Datenbankverbindung drin gibt sobald
du was startest, so und das ist das was ich
auf dem, der kann ich mir dran erinnern, das ist das was ich an diesem
Tag auf diesem Daily erzählt hab, ist das nicht
viel sinniger, musst du nicht so durch die Brust
ins Auge das ganze hin basteln
sondern ihr kriegt von uns einfach einen CubeCTL
Run Kommando
wenn ihr das startet, startet im richtigen
Namespace einen Container oder einen Pod
ihr bekommt eine shell ihr könnt euer kommando ausführen wir können euch sogar ein skript
reinlegen was dieses kommando beinhaltet und dann detacht ihr euch wieder und das ist danach weg
und braucht keine ressourcen mehr und das so machen sie das jetzt unser debug container ist
mittlerweile richtig fett ich habe angefangen einen debug container zu basteln wo man halt
so alle möglichen Tools hat, die man so braucht, von
NetStat,
JQ,
Weget, Curl, alles mögliche.
So, Container, die man so braucht.
Da kann ich gleich was zu sagen.
Für alles, was man so braucht.
Und mittlerweile, also das war,
ich hab den Container damals aufgesetzt,
ich wollte den gar nicht sonderlich minimal machen,
weil er ist zum Debuggen und läuft nicht permanent.
Ubuntu Jemmy,
was ist Jemmy? 2204?
Ist das 2204?
2204 als Basis
Am Anfang war der Container
Was weiß ich, 300 MB oder so groß
Weiß nicht, was so ein minimal Ubuntu Container ist
Mit ein paar Tools, 300 MB
Nichts wildes
Mittlerweile habe ich so viele Anfragen
Schon bekommen, was in diesen
Container alles rein soll, dass der Container
Jetzt 1,3 GB
Groß ist
1,3 GB
Was da alles drin ist
Da ist sogar das komplette Google Cloud CLI drin, weil Leute gesagt haben, manchmal wollen wir da auf irgendwelche APIs in der Google Cloud und dann können wir da nicht in Google Cloud CLI reinmachen.
Sogar Google Cloud CLI drin.
Allein schon, das ist irgendwie 500 MB groß oder so.
Hast du mal NixOS ausprobiert?
Ne, aber ich benutze Nix Package Manager.
27 GB Container.
Also wenn allein der Container das Image
27 Gigabyte enthält, ist es ein richtig...
Dann ist es der fetteste Container, den ich glaube ich
je gesehen habe.
Also ich habe schon
Pots gesehen, die viel Speicherplatz benutzt haben
am Ende, weil die Persistent Disks haben.
Dort beispielsweise
Polygon, Blockchain Node, Sachen drauf
sinken und sowas.
Aber ein Container-Image
mit 27 Gig habe ich bis jetzt noch nicht gesehen.
Wie managt ihr Kubernetes-Ressourcen mit Argo CD?
Wir werden es glücklicherweise mit Argo CD machen in Zukunft.
Da freue ich mich schon drauf.
Und wisst ihr, was das Gute ist?
Ich kenne mich mit Argo CD aus.
Wir haben sogar vor zwei Jahren mal einen Argo CD Stream gemacht.
Da habe ich sogar schon Ahnung ein bisschen von.
Wir werden es in Zukunft Gott sei Dank mit Argo CD machen.
Aktuell ist es weder mit Argo CD noch mit Flux.
Flux ist ja outdated, overrated, she baited
ist ja auf dem absteigenden Ast
wir machen das gar nicht so richtig
wir haben so ein oldschool Deployment-Tool
mit Bash-Skripts, es ist nicht Jenkins
es ist irgendein Deployment-Tool
was die sich von irgendeiner Marketing
guten Verkaufs
Marketing-Verkaufsabteilung haben aufschwätzen
lassen, letztendlich ist es so ein glorified
Bash-Skript-Runner, der
kubectl-commands ausführt
historisch gewachsen, war schon
da
Aber es wird in Zukunft
Argo CD. Das wird ein bisschen dauern,
aber da freue ich mich drauf. Endlich mal ein gescheites Tool.
Okay, also was haben wir hier?
Ich habe dich vorhin gefragt, was du machen würdest, wenn du
heutzutage nochmal aus der Physie-Ausbildung kommst.
Worauf würdest du dich konzentrieren?
Ich habe grob Dinge,
die mich interessieren, beziehungsweise
was ich ausschließe. Was kannst du ausschließen?
Kobold auf dem Mainframe?
Aber ich bin noch ein bisschen lost. Wie hast du deinen
Weg gefunden. Boah, ey,
das ist eine Frage, da muss ich echt, da muss ich
ein bisschen drüber nachdenken.
Worauf ich mich
heute konzentrieren würde, ja,
gut, das kann ich schlecht sagen,
weil
ich mache jetzt ja das, worauf
ich Bock habe,
das mache ich aber
unter anderem, weil
sich so ergeben hat über die letzten
17 Jahre.
Also wenn ich heute nochmal eine Ausbildung machen würde...
Also ich würde wahrscheinlich wieder eine Physie-Ausbildung machen.
Was ist der Vorteil von Argos?
Es ist das einzige, was es gibt in der Richtung.
Mittlerweile.
Früher gab es auch Flux.
Flux ist nicht mehr angesagt. Es gibt jetzt was Neues, ich habe vergessen wie es heißt. Das ist aber noch sehr Alpha.
Wahrscheinlich würde ich wieder eine Physie-Ausbildung machen und wahrscheinlich würde ich im Endeffekt auch wieder bei Cloud-Infrastruktur und Automatisierung landen.
Schrägstrich so ein bisschen im DevOps-Bereich. Man kann ja nicht immer richtig den Finger drauf legen, weil ich programmiere gerne.
das habe ich auch schon während meiner Ausbildung gerne gemacht
und dementsprechend passt das
einfach gut für mich
gerade was
Infrastruktur und Automatisierung angeht
wenn man nämlich sich für Infrastruktur
und so Admin Linux Sachen
interessiert plus gerne programmiert
dann lernt man
dann landet man irgendwann halt auch mal bei
Automatisierung schrägstrich
interner Toolentwicklung und sowas
Flux ist nicht mehr
angesagt, weil Flux soweit ich
das gelesen habe
den größten Supporter,
den sie hatten, verloren haben.
Ansible.
Ja, Ansible auch.
Hauptsächlich Terraform.
Und tatsächlich auch interne Tool-Entwicklung.
Es ist alles safe bei Flux.
Okay, dann habe ich...
Ich habe das letztens irgendwo gesehen.
Dass Flux angeblich...
Die Firma hinter Flux,
dass sie selbst nicht mehr Flux supportet oder sowas.
Vielleicht ist es auch Fake News,
was ich euch jetzt erzähle.
Ich habe das irgendwo gelesen.
Die sind pleite.
Also wenn die Firma hinter Flux pleite ist,
weiß ich nicht, ob alles in trockenen Tüchern bei Flux ist.
Ja.
Ach, die sind jetzt woanders und machen daran weiter.
Also ich nenne es mal interne Tool-Entwicklung.
Also zum Beispiel,
eines der Sachen, was wir auch im Stream gemacht haben,
wo ich mir jetzt keine Gedanken machen muss, ob ich da irgendwas erzählen oder nicht erzählen soll.
Wir haben beispielsweise einen Customized Prometheus-Exporter gebaut für unsere Blockchain-Anwendung.
Ich kann das jetzt nur so grob umschreiben, die beispielsweise so Sachen exportiert wie Blockage, Transaktionen pro Block und solche Geschichten,
weil die Software, die wir da verwenden, das Standard-Mesing nicht kann.
Wir haben quasi einen Sidecar-Container gebaut, der da mitläuft und der hat jetzt einen in Go programmierten, customised, von uns entwickelten, für uns entwickelten Prometheus-Exporter, der genau die Metriken bereitstellt, die wir brauchen.
und die die software halt so an sich nicht raus rückt weil die software die wir da verwenden für
unser blog change den zwar eine api die man abfragen kann die api leuchtet lauscht aber
logischerweise nur auf localhost und die gibt auch nicht das alles her was wir an metriken
einsammeln wollen deswegen haben wir einen eigenen prometheus exporter gebaut der sich
lokal seit kalt quasi zugriff auf die sachen die da in diesem pott auf localhost laufen und der
ruft sich Sachen von der API auf,
formatiert die ein bisschen um, berechnet noch ein paar
Sachen aus, bereitet die ein bisschen
anders aus und stellt die dann an einem Metrix-Endpunkt
bereit, sodass Prometheus die einsammeln
kann. Und das ist
sowas, wo ich sagen muss, das macht mir richtig Bock,
so Dinger zu bauen.
Und
wahrscheinlich würde ich
über kurz oder lang auch wieder in so einer Richtung,
in so einer Ecke landen,
weil
da kann ich alles machen, was
mich interessiert. Ich interessiere mich
für Linux, ich interessiere mich für Cloud,
generell für Hardware, für Infrastruktur, auch für
Cloud-Infrastruktur, für
wie man Sachen automatisch machen kann und
ich programmier gerne. Das heißt,
irgendwie passt das einfach gut.
Hauptsache in Go. Die Sache, warum
ich es in Go programmiert habe, ich wollte das witzigerweise
zuerst in .NET programmieren.
Warum ich es im Endeffekt doch
in Go entwickelt habe, ist, weil ich
ein Self-Contained Binary haben wollte,
was überall läuft.
Nicht so wild, ja, wir reden hier
von dem Container, dann würde man auch versetzen.
Aber ich wollte das Container-Image
am Ende, was wir zusätzlich injecten müssen,
möglichst klein halten.
Und ich glaube,
das Container-Image ist am Ende auch nur 8 MB
oder sowas groß jetzt, was da zusätzlich
dazu kommt.
Das habe ich auch presentated
bei unserer letzten Abteilungsversammlung
Ende letzten Jahres.
Weil, wie ich schon öfters gesagt habe, es reicht
nicht nur, coole Sachen zu machen.
Man muss das, so blöd es klingt, aber öfters mal breittreten.
Aber ich glaube, ich würde wahrscheinlich wieder in dieser Richtung lernen.
In dieser Richtung, in dieser Richtung landen.
Irgendwie Richtung Cloud, Infrastruktur und Automatisierung und interner Tool-Entwicklung, nenne ich es mal so.
Alles in einem.
Ich weiß nicht, was es da für ein hübsches Buzzword mittlerweile gibt, um das zusammenzufassen.
Unter DevOps läuft ja gefühlt auch mittlerweile alles.
Keine Ahnung.
Aber wahrscheinlich würde ich wieder in dieser Richtung landen, weil es einfach gut zu mir passt.
weil das so fast alles enthält, was mich interessiert und was mir Spaß macht.
Also wahrscheinlich würde ich wieder sowas machen.
Dementsprechend kann ich dir halt auch nicht sagen, was für dich passt.
Weil wahrscheinlich wird für dich was ganz anderes spannend sein.
Oder vielleicht nur Teile von dem und andere Teile dazu oder keine Ahnung.
Ja, und das hat sich über die Jahre halt letztendlich so entwickelt.
Ich meine, man darf nicht vergessen, wir haben quasi DevOps gemacht in der alten Firma, bevor es das Wort DevOps gab.
Wir haben im Jahr 2000, boah, wann war denn das? 2010 oder so?
Oder wann war Puppet Release Date?
Ich weiß gar nicht, wann die erste Wikipedia, wann die erste Version von Puppet rausgekommen ist.
2005, na so früh noch
ich sag mal so 2009, 2010
oder so, haben wir damals
angefangen, unsere Server
aufbauten und Konfigurationen
mit Puppet zu automatisieren, verwendet heute
keiner mehr, ich weiß nicht, kennt das überhaupt noch jemand
die meisten Leute verwenden heute Ansible, damals war
Puppet angesagt, davor gab es eigentlich
nur noch CFEngine und das war noch ekliger
ja, wir haben damals angefangen
unsere
Serverkonfigurationen
automatisieren mit puppet und haben das dann auch gleich ich weiß nicht wann mal geht release war
auch so 2010 rum als das angefangen hat ja 2005 war so 2010 als es so richtig angefangen hat fahrt
aufzunehmen wir haben das dann tatsächlich gemacht als eine der ersten würde ich fast auch schon
ganz war damals überhaupt nicht verbreitet als wie man das heute so schön nennt infrastruktur
S-Code nennt man das.
Damals kam niemand auf die Idee,
das so zu nennen.
Also quasi nicht irgendwelche Sachen
aufzubauen, danach Skripte laufen zu lassen,
sondern dass man eine
Sprache hatte, in dem man
deklarativ festgelegt hat,
so soll die Kiste am Endeffekt aussehen,
mach halt mal. So macht man das ja
mit Ansible heute auch. Wobei Ansible deutlich,
muss man sagen, deutlich
Prozedural, ich kann das nicht
aussprechen prozeduraler heißt das so ist als papat hast du viel abstrakter gesagt so soll es
sein mach mal bei ansatz ja oftmals auch so nach dem motto zuerst das hier ausführen das hier dann
die berechtigung setzen dann dass ihr dann dass ihr dann dass sie das da das tage auspacken dahin
aber also die server konfiguration in einer anderen sprache definiert hat und das dann
quasi ihr plan lassen hat von einem tool das war damals ziemlich neu heute läuft so was unter
infrastructure as code und da gibt es noch gibt es ja noch mehr basswörter
githubs und devops und wobei das zwei unterschiedliche geschichte sind das
eine ist er aus dem kubernetes umfeld gab es damals alles gar nicht von der
bezeichnung also wir haben quasi schon devops und infrastructure as code gemacht
bevor es das wort gab und da habe ich festgestellt das ist genau meins ich
programmieren gerne ich automatisieren gerne server aufbauten habe ich da im
dem zuge festgestellt und ich bin dann da immer weiter rein gerutscht und
irgendwann habe ich mich alleine um unserer in fall um unsere infrastruktur
source code repo gekümmert wo teilweise bis zu 4000 kisten mit versorgt wurden
4000 linux kisten weil ich alleine für zuständig ich habe dann irgendwann noch
verstärkung bekommen das war aber mehrfach verstärkung bekommen das war
aber auch immer meistens nur von kurzer Dauer.
Ja.
Und als ich weg bin, hat das dann
glücklicherweise jemand anderes übernommen.
Aber die haben jetzt mittlerweile
eh viel mehr anderweitig gelöst
als, also keine Ahnung, wie es da jetzt läuft.
Ja.
Und dementsprechend musste ich mich
gezwungenermaßen
von Anfang an,
weil das war neu, da gab es noch nicht so viel, wo man
abgucken könnte, mit auseinandersetzen,
okay, wie kann man dann sowas am besten handeln? Ich habe das mit aufgebaut und ich habe mich da jahrelang auch alleine drum gekümmert oder hauptsächlich zumindest alleine drum gekümmert.
Ich muss mir dann so Dinge ausdenken, okay, wie kriege ich denn die Leute dazu, dass sie sich beim Entwickeln nicht ins Gehege kommen gegenseitig?
Gerade was Infrastruktur angeht, geht das ja ganz gut. Also es ist ja oftmals so, dass unterschiedliche Leute für unterschiedliche Server oder unterschiedliche Teile zuständig sind.
Also sie kommen sich nicht so oft ins Gehege, aber gerade bei grundlegenden Sachen, wie welche Basispackages auf ein System drauf kommen, auf jedes oder wie läuft die AD-Anmeldung und solche Geschichten, da sind sich die Leute schon in die Quere gekommen.
Also wie können die Leute parallel an ihrer Serverkonfiguration entwickeln, ohne sich ins Gehege zu kommen und wie machen wir das, dass wir das ordentlich testen können einmal im Monat und wie schaffen wir es, dass Sachen, die kaputt sind, gefixt werden können für beispielsweise die produktive Umgebung, aber gleichermaßen auch wieder in den Entwicklungsstand, in den aktuellen Entwicklungsstand zurückkommen.
Also da musste ich mich zwangsläufig mit Git auseinandersetzen und wie man das am besten macht.
Mit wann taggt man was, wann macht man einen Branch und wie bringt man den Leuten bei,
dass die am besten nicht alle parallel in Master rumfuschen, sondern Feature-Branches machen und sowas.
Heute ist das, würde ich mal sagen, relativ easy.
Es gibt auch sehr viele Guides und How-To's, die man sich angucken kann.
Ja, und fängt an mit, wie benennen die Leute, wie sollte man das am richtigen benennen.
Es gibt da mittlerweile ganz, äh, ganze fertigen, äh, so Konzepte, so, wie benennt man Comment-Messages so, dass man am Ende noch durchblickt, wie das Ganze, das konnte man sich damals überhaupt nicht abgucken, ja.
Und ich muss sagen, das, was wir dann am Ende gemacht haben, ist erstaunlich nah zu dem dran, was ich heute eigentlich auch etabliert habe.
Mit mehr als ein paar besonderheiten ja zum beispiel dass wir einen permanenten brand hatte für jedes environment also es gab
Einen permanenten dev branch einen permanenten in pratsch und permanenten port branch
In dem man immer nur das jeweilige aktuelle stand rein gemeldet wurde
Aber im kurs zum ganzen ist das ziemlich so wie man es heute eigentlich auch macht
Das war schon nicht schlecht.
Ich denke mal
Hätte es das in der Form nicht gegeben, würde ich heute auch was anderes machen.
Aber ich habe dann halt dadurch festgestellt, dass das das ist
Was mir gefällt.
Und wenn ihr mal
Wenn ihr mal in der Jahrzehnte
Das ist jetzt übertrieben.
Naja, wobei
2010 oder so ging es los
2023 bin ich geweckt
also wenn ihr mal über 10 Jahre
hauptsächlich
Sachen lest
die andere Leute entwickelt haben
und ihr euch quasi täglich damit rumschlagen müsst
mit Merch Requests von Leuten
und euch das angucken müsst
man lernt relativ gut
sich da rein zu denken
was andere Leute fabrizieren.
Und ich habe,
ich will es nicht
zu sehr loben, aber ich habe
sehr oft auf den ersten Blick
Sachen gesehen, die nicht funktionieren
werden. Allein schon, weil ich mir
so viele verschiedene Sachen angeguckt habe, von allen
möglichen Leuten, wo ich sofort gesehen habe,
das wird so nicht funktionieren, wo derjenige,
der es gebaut hat, nicht daran gedacht hat.
Das geht los von einfachen
Ich habe mich verschrieben, zu
Ha, ich weiß aber,
dass mein
LDAP-S schreiben muss, anstatt LDAP
an der Stelle, weil ich schon 500 Mal
gesehen habe und derjenige, der das
gebaut hat, halt noch nicht.
Ich wusste, okay, das muss LDAP-S sein und nicht LDAP
an der Stelle und solche Geschichten.
Ich habe sehr viel entdeckt,
einfach beim Durchgucken,
nach all den Jahren, wo ich schon gleich wusste,
okay, wenn ich das merge, wird
spätestens ein Test auf die Nase fallen,
weil es nicht funktioniert.
also da hatte ich schon echt den durchblick mit der zeit
manche sachen sind auch schwierig zu testen
manche sachen sind schwierig zu testen und gerade so sachen mit ldap s und ldap das
fällt ihr vielleicht erst auf ab einer umgebung etwas höheren umgebung wo du dann entweder
wieder wirklich dann auch das erste mal wirklich dass das exakt um drei ecken
irgendwie angebunden hast oder wo dann auch entforscht wird dass es verendet
was auch immer das war zum beispiel mit ldap s aber so schön dass in der theorie
klingt alle umgebung müssen immer gleich sein umgebung sind nie gleich also diese
sache mit ja unsere test ist genauso wie brot das erzählt was ich immer gerne
aber in wirklichkeit ist das stimmt das nicht ich kenne keinen wo das stimmt
Ich kenne keinen, wo das stimmt, dass Test gleich ist wie Prot.
Allein schon aus Kostenfrage kann das ja rein von dem Skalierungsgrad her oder von der Anzahl der Kisten nicht stimmen.
Das höchste der Gefühle ist, dass die Systeme halbwegs gleich aufgebaut sind, aber die Anzahl ist in Prot auch eindeutig höher.
Aber selbst das ist nicht so, weil, nehmen wir mal ein ganz einfaches Beispiel, Anbindung zu Drittanbietern, ja, die hast du in der Regel nicht im Test. Im Test hast du, wenn du Glück hast, so irgendwas Nachgebautes oder so ein Ding wie, ja, wir testen mal, dass theoretisch eine Verbindung nach außen geht oder sowas, aber du hast im Test meistens gar keine Verbindung nach außen.
Wenn du eine Verbindung nach außen hast, wirst du in Test nicht dich zu irgendeiner externen Schnittstelle verbinden.
Also Test und Brot ist nie gleich, wie oft das auch immer erzählt wird.
Ja, das ist nicht so.
Und dementsprechend sind manche Sachen auch echt schwer zu testen.
Oder auch Zertifikate. Zertifikate ist auch ein beliebtes Thema.
Oder der Weg, wie Zertifikate ausgestellt werden, manchmal anders ist in Prod wie zu Test.
So in Test, so nach dem Motto, in Test will keiner für Zertifikate Geld bezahlen.
Da gibt es entweder ein Self-Sign-Zertifikat oder irgendwie was anderes, krückenmäßiges,
irgendwie einer verwendeten Zertifikat für alles oder whatever.
Und dann ab Int und Prod gibt es dann ein richtig echtes Zertifikat, wo der Weg dann auch funktionieren muss.
sei es später vieles über Let's Encrypt oder halt auch noch bezahlte Zertifikate.
2010 war noch eine Zeit, da war mit Let's Encrypt nichts.
Da musstest du für jedes Zertifikat noch einen Antrag an irgendeine Zertifizierungsstelle schicken,
die dir dann Codes zurückgeschickt haben und sowas.
Also Test und Brot gleich kannst vergessen.
Da haben wir aber, und ich habe das ja in diesen 10 Jahren miterlebt,
wir haben enorme Fortschritte gemacht mit Containerisierung.
Das ist auch, finde ich, der Fall, wo Containerisierung wirklich scheinen kann, dass zumindest auf Anwendungsebene betreffend, Systeme drumherum, wo dann die Container drauf laufen, ist wieder was anderes, aber zumindest auf Anwendungsebene der Unterschied zwischen, wo die Anwendung dann wirklich läuft, wenn sie live ist, versus wo die Anwendung läuft und drumherum, wo sie getestet wird, zumindest Anwendung und drumherum so ähnlich wie möglich ist.
also da hat sich vieles getan in den letzten jahren zumindest test und
brot gleich wird es wird es nicht passieren und ja und da ist mir sehr viel schon aufgefallen
immer bevor es den eigentlichen entwicklern dann aufgefallen entwickler oder halt zuständigen
dafür aufgefallen ist ich habe da wirklich wirklich gut durchgeblickt wie fandest du
das Go-Porting von TS. Spannend
fand ich das.
Wir haben uns ja nicht viel angeguckt dazu.
Außer
dass es so ist, ja.
Übrigens, da muss ich jetzt mal was zu sagen.
Ihr habt das ja wahrscheinlich mitgekriegt, dass
Microsoft Type, den TypeScript
Compiler,
portiert hat oder portiert nach Go.
Übrigens, es ist genau aus den Gründen,
ich hab mir ein Interview mit Anders Heilsberg
angeguckt, das ist der TypeScript
Erfinder oder Miterfinder von TypeScript
und auch von C Sharp, witzigerweise.
habe ich mir angeguckt
der Grund den ich genannt habe im Stream
warum sie es nicht in Rust programmiert haben
ist genau der Grund den Anders Heilsberg auch gesagt hat
ich hab Mutmast im Stream
warum Microsoft den TypeScript Compiler nicht in Rust rewritet
aus zwei Gründen erstens Entwicklungsgeschwindigkeit
und zweitens
weil die in dem Compiler wahrscheinlich jede Menge
selbst referenzierten Datenstrukturen, selbst referenzierenden Datenstrukturen haben.
Und genau das hat er als Beispiel angebracht.
Und gesagt, dass es in Rust absoluter Abfuck ist.
Genau das hat er gesagt, habe ich richtig gelegen.
Und was ich viel interessanter finde ist, oder woran man sieht,
dass Anders Heilsberg
echt pfeifett ist.
Die Frage ist jetzt natürlich, die man sich stellen kann,
warum Go
und warum nicht
C-Sharp?
Kann man sich ja fragen.
Ich meine, C-Sharp ist Microsoft
interne Geschichte,
hauptsächlich, ja,
hier dran arbeiten
und
TypeScript auch. Warum hat man
TypeScript, also, hier,
Das ist die Ankündigung davon.
Warum hat man TypeScript nicht in C Sharp entwickelt, zum Beispiel?
Den TypeScript-Compiler.
Einer der Punkte, die er noch genannt hat, war,
dass Go und wie der TypeScript-Compiler aufgebaut ist
und wie dort Datenstrukturen und so verwendet werden,
dass das...
Also ihr Ziel ist es nicht, den TypeScript-Compiler neu zu entwickeln.
Ihr Ziel ist es, den TypeScript-Compiler zu portieren in eine andere Sprache, die es ja unter anderem auch schneller macht, aber das Verhalten exakt beizubehalten.
Also alle Bugs sollen da bleiben und alles wie es ist, soll so bleiben.
Das heißt, die portieren das Zeile für Zeile und die haben gesagt, TypeScript ist relativ ähnlich zu Go und dementsprechend bietet sich Go an.
wohingegen es in Rust so gar nicht möglich wäre und aufgrund der selbstreferenzierten Datenstrukturen in Rust ja auch immer sehr eklig,
das ist das, was ich auch vermutet habe, könnte man sich jetzt aber fragen, warum nicht C-Sharp?
Man könnte ja durchaus auch sagen, ey, TypeScript und C und C, so unterschiedlich ist das nicht.
Ne, aber sie haben sich explizit dafür entschieden, es nicht in C-Sharp zu machen, weil Go besser passt.
und ich finde, daran sieht man,
was einen
ultra high IQ Senior
Pokers Engineer auszeichnet,
wie Anders Heilsberg,
der nimmt nicht einfach irgendwas aus,
wie soll man es mal nennen, so ideologischen Gründen,
sondern das, wo er denkt,
dass es am besten passt.
Und das ist glaube ich
auch eine Sache, wo man sich
wirklich was von abschneiden kann,
nicht darauf zu beharren, ich muss das
jetzt in XY machen, weil
ich das fanboye, sondern
ich mach das in XY,
weil sich das am besten anbietet.
Das können ja die unterschiedlichsten Gründe sein.
Hier sind es die Gründe, warum
das TypeScript sinnvoll ist.
Bei Projekten von euch oder von mir kann das was anderes
sein. Und ich finde auch einen Punkt, den man
nicht vernachlässigen darf, der
aber so im Buzzword
Bullshit Bingo ein bisschen vernachlässigt wird,
ist, man hat Entwickler, die sich
damit auskennen.
Ja, also wenn jetzt die Frage ist, machen wir was Neues in Java oder in Rust oder in Go oder in TypeScript oder in Framework XYZ, wenn man sich dann mal fragt, ey, mit was haben wir eigentlich die meiste Erfahrung?
und es ist meinetwegen
ExpressJS als Backend
und alles Node.js, Javascript
das ist vielleicht nicht mehr
hip und cool oder nicht so trendy
wie das in Rust zu machen und dann
auf Stack Overflow, äh nicht auf Stack Overflow
auf Reddit posten zu können
unser neuer
Microservice läuft in Rust und das ist
wie, oder auf LinkedIn
irgendwelche geilen Posts zu machen
Ist vielleicht cooler, wenn man das in Rust entwickelt,
aber sich zu fragen, ey, guck mal,
wir haben
jahrzehntelange Erfahrung in
sagen wir mal,
Node.js, JavaScript-Entwicklung
und mit Express.js als Backend.
In was machen wir unseren neuen Service?
Machen wir das jetzt in irgendwas, wo wir gar keine Ahnung
von haben? Wo wir auch keinen Entwickler
von haben, die da langjährige Erfahrungen mit haben?
Wo wir die Frameworks nicht kennen?
Ist das wirklich sinnvoll?
Einfach nur, weil es hip ist?
Was ist denn in Rust gerade hip?
Was ist denn da das hippe Framework?
Wie heißt das?
Tokio. Tokio für Async und Hyper oder nee.
Wie heißt das in Rust?
Tokio. Ja, Tokio ist die Async.
Ja, also macht man das in Rust und irgendwelche Rust-Geschichten nur weil es cool ist oder hat es auch einen Vorteil?
Da muss man sich halt überlegen.
Okay, und der eine Vorteil ist eindeutig.
Wir machen es in JavaScript weiter, weil wir da jahrzehnte Erfahrung haben.
Okay, man könnte aber sagen, ah Moment, wir machen das in Rust, weil wir beispielsweise die Anwendung auch als WebAssembly irgendwie da verwursten wollen.
Dann kann es wieder Sinn machen, aber man muss das wirklich mal realistisch abwägen, wenn man neue Sachen startet, was die Vor- und Nachteile sind.
Und einfach nur Sachen zu machen, weil sie hip sind, ist nicht unbedingt der High IQ Move.
Das ist für private Projekte vielleicht ganz nice. Ich mache auch Sachen lieber in irgendwelchen hippen neuen Dingern als in Java oder so. Ich habe von Java auch keine Ahnung. Oder als in Kobol. Aber das muss für irgendwelche Business Enterprise Sachen nicht die beste Variante sein.
Und ich finde, daran sieht man, dass Anders Heilsberg wirklich Five Heads Senior Poggers Engineer ist,
dass er gesagt hat, ey, wir machen das Ganze in Go.
Weil Go die beste Sprache ist für das, was wir machen wollen.
Und weil wir von Go, wenn wir das in Go haben, die besten Vorteile draus oder die besten Verbesserungen draus ziehen können.
Deswegen verstehe ich, dass das in Go gemacht wird, nach dem Video auch.
habe ich schon beantwortet glaube ich
denn das dann echte meetings oder auch via teams also wenn wir vor ort sind ist das immer hybrid
war hocken die leute im besprechungsraum manche remote und manche nicht manche sitzen halt dann
im besprechungsraum vor ort story von der frau die man im floristik großmarkt business
gab als die arbeit seit zehn jahren salopp gesagt senior logistik leiter g
senior logistikerin total zufrieden und darf den ganzen tag operativ arbeiten
jetzt wechseln sie ihre vorgesetzte woanders hin und sie hat angst dass
jetzt selbst lied von er das will sie wahrscheinlich weil sie sich keinen bock
auf keinen bock auf den stress hat
ja kann ich verstehen dass deshalb das problem wenn du automatisch da irgendwie
Leute, die bei drei nicht auf dem
Baum sind, in Positionen drängst,
wo sie gar nicht hinkommen wollen
oder hin möchten.
Man muss es auch mal realistisch
sehen.
Die allerwenigsten Techniker
sind gute Manager.
Das ist einfach so.
Und es sind auch sehr wenige
Manager gute Techniker.
Das heißt nicht, dass nicht mal
aus der Technikecke
mal der ein oder andere gute Manager
erwachsen,
entwachsen kann.
Und das heißt auch nicht, dass jemand, der mal
nur weil er
im Management aktiv ist,
für immer keine Ahnung von Technik
haben muss.
Aber die besten Manager
sind gute Techniker, die keine Manager sein
wollen, das sehe ich nicht so.
habe ich schon gelesen
ok
das gehört damals ja das go back and in sie in rust danach hat sich rausgehört sein back jetzt
Ja.
Echt, ist Fischshell jetzt in Rust? Das wusste ich nicht.
Rust ist super für CLE-Anwendungen und Compiler.
Da kann man sich jetzt drüber streiten.
Also gerade für den TypeScript-Compiler war es laut Aussage unter anderem vom TypeScript-Erfinder keine gute Wahl.
Was ich auch verstehen kann, generell hat Rust ja seine Probleme mit selbstreferenzierenden Sachen.
Machen eine Linklist in Rust und sowas.
Ich weiß nicht, wie das heute ist, aber solche Sachen waren in der Zeit, wo ich mich ein bisschen mit Rust beschäftigt habe, immer problematisch.
Ich bin mir gar nicht sicher, ob das immer so eine gute Sache ist, das in Rust zu bauen.
Für CLI-Anwendungen gebe ich dir recht, für CLI-Anwendungen ist Rust super.
Gerade weil du die sehr klein und sehr einfach Standalone bekommst.
aber muss dazu sagen das geht mit go genauso sogar einen ticken besser wie ich finde weil
du gar keine abhängigkeiten mehr brauchst und die go binaries wahrscheinlich auch nicht so
viel größer sind das ist passiert einwendungen problematisch ist wahrscheinlich go was das
angeht noch das bessere ökosystem hat da bin ich bin nicht sicher aber auf jeden fall hat
Go den schnelleren Entwicklungsspeed
als Rust. Egal wie gut du Rust kannst.
Also wenn du jemanden
nimmst, der gleich gut
also jemanden der gut Rust kann,
jemanden der gut Go kann, der wird in Go immer schneller fertig sein
als in Rust.
WebAssembly, WebAssembly ist auch angesagt.
Ja.
Der TypeScript Compiler ist in TypeScript meines Wissens nach.
Ist er.
Genau.
Ja.
Wir programmieren ohne Fehler.
Wir.
Hier.
Das heißt aber nicht, dass die ganze Welt das kann.
Die müssen eindeutig alle mehr wuppler stream gucken da könnten die das auch
Wie man sieht bei mir ist das ja alles immer fehlerfrei
Bei uns haben wir drei monate neu darüber diskutiert was im test nicht wie ein prot ist er
das ist wird aber trotzdem nie sein am ende
Ja, das trifft es eigentlich ziemlich gut als Zusammenfassung.
Du definierst alles dein Zeug in
Jammer
Es muss nicht Jammer sein, Argo CD kann auch
Helmcharts und solche Geschichten, aber sagen wir mal
Du definierst deinen ganzen Kram in Jammer
Und Jammer applyt das dann in deinen
Cluster und hält quasi das, was in deinem
Git-Repo, in deinem nicht Anwendungs-Repo
Vielleicht in deinem Infrastruktur-Repo
Falls du zwei Sachen hast
Hält das synchron
Das ist ja eh so eine Frage
wo diese Sachen dann alle gepflegt werden sollen.
Also ich bin der Meinung, man sollte alles,
was notwendig ist
an Ressourcen und Dingern
jammeltechnisch pflegen im
Anwendungsrepo.
Da kann man nicht drüber schreien.
Aber ein Infrastruktur-Repo
so als Zwischenschritt kann trotzdem sinnvoll sein.
Wo dann eben die ganzen Sachen aus
den Anwendungsrepos
quasi eingebettet
werden und es dann
pro stage konfiguriert wird weil nur weil du konflikt um die anwendung
kombiniertes laufen zu lassen im anwendungs repo trainer liegen hast heißt
es ja noch lange nicht dass dort auch die config liegen muss wie diese sachen
pro umgebung pro stage konfiguriert werden müssen das heißt dafür kann man
dann noch ein eigenes infrastruktur repo machen oder ein infrastruktur pro stage
machen, wenn man das will.
Und diese Sachen
synkt dann Argo CD
in den Cluster und hält quasi den Stand,
wie er in dem Repo ist, gleich zu dem Stand,
wie es im Cluster ist. Das heißt, du kannst
in dem Fall, und das ist eines der Vorteile
von
Tools wie Argo CD oder
Flux, ich hab mir ja sagen lassen, bei Flux ist
alles nice, obwohl ich dachte, sie sind
auf dem absteigenden Ast. Du kannst
nicht mehr vergessen, was
nachzuflegen. Das ist ja sowas,
was man öfters mal hat, so nach dem Motto, man baut was mit Terraform auf oder man hat mal irgendwo was aufgebaut,
hat dann vielleicht, sagen wir mal Oldschool, ja, ganz Oldschool,
man hat eine Linux-Kiste hingestellt und hat dann ein Konfigurationsskript, was drüber läuft
und den Server so konfiguriert, wie er sein soll.
Und jetzt kommt jemand zu dir und sagt, Max, ey, wir brauchen aber Leseberechtigung für User XYZ auf dem Ordner.
Also gehe ich per SSH auf die Kiste drauf, sage, eine Ahnung, chmods u plus x g plus r, was auch immer auf irgendeinen Ordner und dann vergesse ich das in meinem Setup-Skript einzutragen und wenn das nächste Mal hingestellt wird, gibt es das gleiche Problem wieder.
Das ist ein Problem, das gab es seit Jahrzehnten. Das ist ein Problem, was zumindest für Kubernetes Cluster mit Argo CD weitgehend gefixt wird. Weil du machst nichts mehr, gar nichts mehr am Cluster selbst, sondern du checkst alles in den Git Repo ein und Argo CD applyt die Ressourcen dann für dich in den Cluster.
das ist im prinzip zum größten teil das ist eigentlich alles in anführungsstrichen was
agro cd macht agro cd selbst bringt noch ein web interface mit wurde dann schon gucken kannst was
welche ressourcen wurden angelegt wie hält da hängt das ganze zusammen kannst du kannst du
auch rollbacks mitmachen irgendwie bekannt unsicher wie wir haben den stream mit agro
cd gemacht da haben wir das gemacht ja solche geschichte also das ist wirklich nice wo es ja
wo es hier natürlich nichts bringt ist bei den cluster ressourcen selbst also du brauchst erst
mal einen funktionierenden cluster damit agro cd an funktion kuban das klasse mit agro cd
funktioniert agro cd kann sich selbst verwalten man das machen will so ein bisschen diskussion
gibt es da immer sollte sich agro cd selbst verwalten oder nicht aber das erstellen des
clusters kann agro cd nicht machen also wenn du sagst ich brauche einen cluster sagen wir
bei google ich brauche ein kubernetes cluster mit den und den node types dafür ist agro cd nix
agro cd ist dann wirklich nur für die konfiguration von anwendung in dem cluster oder theoretisch auch
vom cluster selbst aber der cluster muss erst mal da sein agro cd muss einmalig installiert werden
Aber dann hast du das Problem nicht mehr mit
Du kannst was vergessen
Rekordvideos geguckt
Ich mache auch mal wieder demnächst auf YouTube was
Mittlerweile bin ich 30
Familie feiern
Ja
Ich bin auch mittlerweile 40
Kann man sich gar nicht vorstellen
Ich werde dieses Jahr 41
Es ist so, dass Leute
Mit denen ich online
Dinger gemacht habe, sind mittlerweile auch schon
Vater geworden.
Und haben Familie und alles.
Also hat sich viel getan die letzten Jahre.
Ich meine, ich habe 2000...
Wann habe ich angefangen?
Wann habe ich angefangen auf YouTube?
2010?
15 Jahre oder so?
Nee, das nicht.
Das habe ich ja gerade versucht zu erklären, bevor ich das gesehen habe.
Also mit Terraform musst du schon noch dein Cluster aufbauen.
Wenn du jetzt allerdings Clusteraufbau und Clusterkonfiguration miteinander vermischt hast,
man kann ja in Terraform auch CubeCTL-Gedöns machen,
man kann in Terraform auch Kubernetes-Yammels reinpacken,
dann könntest du vielleicht dein Terraform etwas entschlacken
Und quasi nur den Clusteraufbau oder die Infrastrukturkonfiguration, was nicht innerhalb des Clusters passiert, in Terraform machen und den Rest mit Argo CD.
Ich habe auch ein GitHub Repo von vor zwei Jahren, wo man das sieht, aber ich empfehle das jetzt ungern, weil ich nicht weiß, wie aktuell das Ganze noch ist, was wir vor zwei Jahren da gemacht haben.
Ja, Naming Convention für Server ist...
Naming Convention ist auch immer so ein Ding.
Das sagt mir gar nichts.
OPC.
Was ist... User Agent?
Das kenne ich nicht.
Sagt mir nichts. Keine Ahnung.
was man für sie video sind das ist gut ich habe einige videos
welche jobbörse ist die beste ehrlich gesagt keine ahnung ich habe nie über jobbörsen den
job gesucht ich habe immer mal was steps down früher geguckt wo man abstand von halten sollte
ist wahrscheinlich LinkedIn.
LinkedIn
kenne ich auch noch vom Hörensagen, wie das da ist
mit Stellenanzeigen.
Ihr kennt ja meinen LinkedIn-Account,
wo ich das Passwort
für vergessen habe.
Wie, man kann das gar nicht mehr aufmachen?
Ne, das da.
Das da bin ich.
Warum?
Wait a minute.
Alter, warum ist LinkedIn eigentlich so eine Dreckskack-
alter da funktioniert nicht mal der zurückknopf richtig muss man sich mal
vorstellen aber okay ich darf das nicht mehr öffnen ohne auch gut
in schädlichen ja
wie groß sind denn dort nette exe falls die die runtime mit schippen die sind
ein bisschen größer wenn es uns selbst content.net also wenn du eine richtige
es gibt ja zwei möglichkeiten self content.net anwendung zu bauen wie wäre es auch anders du
kannst dort net entweder mit framework in kluge oder runtime in kluge tippen dann ich weiß es
nicht genau wie groß das ist ich würde mal sagen so was ist das sein 60 mb oder so könnten wir
jetzt ausprobieren ich weiß nachher von 60 mb aber es gibt ja seit ein paar dort net version
auch die möglichkeit.net ahead of time zu kompilieren also im prinzip so wie
jede andere programmiersprache auch da brauchst du keine runtime mehr die sind
deutlich kleiner
die sind deutlich kleiner da ist immer noch ein bisschen was dabei aber die
sind deutlich kleiner du musst aber auf ein paar sachen
verzichten aber für die meisten leute nicht relevant ja du hast zum beispiel
keine reflection mehr wenn du reflection verwendest kannst du deine .NET
programme nicht klassisch kompilieren ohne runtime weil reflektion mit runtime funktioniert aber die
meisten leute brauchen für sie anwendungen wohl eher keine reflection ich glaube jetzt
habe ich alles durch windows support will ich auch nicht machen
ok aber alles so da können wir jetzt eigentlich nach zwei stunden stream
keck weil alle warum geht das team schon zwei stunden
das pack ich habe jetzt gedacht eine stunde vielleicht oder so anfangen was die github
Trends sind und sagen.
Lasst das Video schauen.
Den Trend, den
den CCC Talk
oder was. Ne, 36 Minuten.
Weiß ich nicht. Oder?
Okay, ich lass euch gleich aussuchen,
was wir gucken.
Crossplane hab ich mir sogar schon mal angeguckt.
Crossplane sieht sehr
nice aus, aber
ich hab keinen so richtigen Anwendungsfall
für gerade bei uns.
Also um es mal grob zu sagen, kannst du mit Crossplane eigene Kubernetes Ressourcen definieren.
Du kannst zum Beispiel eine Ressource definieren, Application nennen wir es mal,
und unter der Haube würde Crossplane dafür sorgen, also du musst dann definieren, was so eine Ressource,
du könntest dann quasi in einem Kubernetes YAML schreiben, Application, Resource Type, Application, die und die URL,
und unter der Haube würde Crossplane für dich, so wie du es definiert hast, dann einen Service anlegen, eine Datenbank anlegen, was auch immer oder externe Service.
Crossplane ist quasi ein bisschen, man könnte sagen, quasi ein bisschen so die Fähigkeiten von Terraform, was Infrastruktur-Provisioning angeht,
beheiratet mit Kubernetes
Konfigurationssprache
und da kann man quasi Custom
Resource Types oder
Custom Resource Definitions heißt es glaube ich,
in Kubernetes, anlegen
und
daraus erstellt dann
Crossplane für einen die Teile
drunter. Da kann man es quasi vereinfachen.
Da kann man zum Beispiel einem Entwickler
sagen, ey, wenn du eine
Anwendung deployen willst, dann musst du nur noch
diese drei Sachen angeben und
in wirklichkeit passiert dann unter der unter der haube es wird eine cloud sql datenbank
professioniert es mit dem service angelegt es wird ein laut balancer angelegt und sowas eigentlich
eine ziemlich coole geschichte mit der ich mich noch nie im detail beschäftigt habe also ich
würde sagen cross plane kommt auf die liste der sachen die wir schaffen uns alle mal anzugucken
im stream aber sag mal so für die eigentliche konfiguration von einem cluster bringt ihr cross
plan auch nichts weil initial brauchst du einmal einen cluster in dem crossplay läuft und sei es
nur dass es ein management cluster ist mit dem du weitere cluster aufbaust aber ein cluster brauchst
du also noch kontakt zum friseur der friseur war sogar letzten stream im stream also im chat
den golem artikel haben wir zu ende gelesen da steht immer viel drin wir sind unten
rasport auf fisch ohne das war gut sein ich gehöre nicht zur rast task force die auf
reddit alles verrastifizieren will ver krusten tiere nicht ich gehöre nicht zu
den kosten tiere auf twitch er auf ihr wolle ja mache ich irgendwann kommt
wieder was auf youtube demnächst irgendwann demnächst ist eine gute
zeitbezeichnung oder weiß ich nicht keine ahnung
also ich war jetzt mal kurz gucken was auf was auf geht habe ich diese woche
trendet ok ai ai ai ai ai ai ai ai ai ok eigentlich ziemlich langweilig was da
so trendet.
So, okay. Moment, Leute.
Erstmal unser Daily-Dosis-Hackerman.
Bevor wir mit YouTube-Videos anfangen.
Und noch einmal
zur Entspannung.
Okay, gut.
Auf geht's.
Also, jetzt ist die Frage,
was wollen wir auf youtube gucken wir hatten zur auswahl den ccc talk den cc3 c4 8 8 wie auch immer
talk was macht ein it system hat ist in einem alu schmelzwerk wo die loge das ist ein re upload ist
nicht original ablocken wurde chat meint das ist ein neuer tag dann könnten wir uns noch angucken
Everything wrong with LinkedIn? Das ist gut, das gucken wir. Das ist 439, das taugt bestimmt.
439 können wir mal schnell einschieben. Dann haben wir noch... Was ist das? What the fuck?
Was ist das? Moment.
Guten Morgen!
Das erinnert mich ein bisschen an wie Apple so easy gab es doch auch so eine zusammen
zusammenschnitt so easy so easy so easy incredible easy easy easy
aber das ist gut das muss ich mir merken falls wir mal irgendwann wieder was zum thema haben
ok
Keine Ahnung, was haben wir denn sonst noch?
How every agile sprint turns into a chaotic mess.
Okay.
Wir gucken uns jetzt erstmal das LinkedIn-Video an.
Danach gucken wir uns den Talk an.
Aber auch nur, weil der Chat sagt, er taugt was.
Bin ich mal gespannt.
Aber man kann sich ja in der Regel immer auf den Chat verlassen, oder?
Chat.
Stimmt das?
Okay, gut.
Noch kurz die Musik ausmachen.
Ich hab den Channel zum ersten Mal gesehen.
Der hat 1, irgendwas Millionen Abos.
Ich bin überhaupt nicht mehr im YouTube Germany
Dings informiert.
LinkedIn ist nur cringe auf einem anderen Niveau.
Wie so?
Ich meine, wir haben alle die dummen Posts gesehen,
wie LinkedIn ist nur ein Kringel auf einem ganz anderen Niveau.
Wie so?
Ich meine, wir haben alle die blöden Posts gesehen, wie...
Ich bin humbl und stolz, dass ich heute beginne,
dass ich in der Position der Jargon-Kommunikations-Spezialistin bin.
Warum? Warum kommt da unten...
Was ist denn das jetzt schon wieder?
Was? Warum?
Halt.
Windows, Alter.
Zu viel AI.
Really?
Okay, wir fangen aber von vorne an.
How so?
I mean, we've all seen the lame posts like
I'm humble and proud to announce that starting today
I'm humble and proud, das ist so ein typisches LinkedIn-Ding, ja.
I have been promoted to the position of jargon communication specialist.
But that's just scratching the surface.
Really?
Sadly, yes.
Der alte, ehemalige Teamleiter von meinem alten Arbeitgeber,
Der ist auch sehr aktiv auf LinkedIn und liked alles und postet irgendwelche Business-Stories.
Also eines der Sachen bei LinkedIn ist ja auch immer Selbstbeweihräucherung, ohne es
zu sehr als Selbstbeweihräucherung wirken zu lassen.
Ich kann nicht mit dem sagen.
Du hast die meisten reichsten Menschen auf der Erde für dein Team gefangen.
Diese Leute sind nie in der Breakroom-Gruppe, die sagen, ich will die Spiele am Montag sehen, also werde ich nicht aufstehen.
Ich weiß, der Boss wird mich nicht fragen.
Ich würde das wahrscheinlich tun.
Ich sage nicht, dass du deinem Mitarbeiter nicht vertrauen kannst, aber du musst nuanced sein.
Bitte, schreib nicht diese fairytale Bilder von dir als coolen Boss.
Untertitelung aufgrund der Audioqualität nicht möglich.
Das trifft es echt ganz gut.
Von irgendwelchen belanglosen Dingern
den Dings schlagen zu,
warum es mich im Business besser macht.
Ich bin heute Morgen die Treppe runtergefallen.
Hat wehgetan.
Aber es hat mich härter gemacht.
und ich bin jetzt viel, viel krasserer Business-Mensch.
Genau.
It's not that bad.
He kind of makes a good point, don't you think?
Absolutely not.
Just listen.
Okay.
The problem with this approach is that you can attribute
some kind of profound meaning to any meaningless situation.
Is that so?
Yes.
Es ist nur ein prätentiöser Weg, mehr tief in die Realität zu erscheinen.
Wie manche Leute denken, dass alles Kunst ist.
Kunst ist subjektiv, oder?
Ja, zu einem gewissen Grad.
Aber manche Leute schauen sich eine literalen Trashcan an und gehen.
Was versucht der Künstler zu erklären?
Ich denke, er will die Lichter aufschneiden, wie wir als Gesellschaft eine Kultur haben,
die aus dem, was uns nicht passt, unsere vorgekündigte Narrative auswirkt.
But it's just a trash can.
Exactly. In the same way, any mundane event can be turned into a lesson about leadership, if you want it to be.
Oh, now I get it. Yeah, that's cringe.
What's that?
Ugh, some people like to write this.
Ich meine, man darf nicht vergessen, ja, es gibt Leute, die schreiben auf LinkedIn einen Post darüber,
dass die quasi, also das sind so ganz abgedrehte Sachen, so nach dem Motto,
für das Business tue ich alles.
Ich hatte die Wahl, auf die Beerdigung
von meinem Vater zu gehen oder
am Laptop Business zu machen.
Selbstverständlich habe ich Business
von der Beerdigung aus erledigt, so nach dem
Motto. Und die posten das dann auf
LinkedIn, als wäre das das geilste
Achievement auf der Welt,
das so zu machen.
Wow.
Das könnte echt
ein LinkedIn-Post sein.
Ich gucke nicht so viel auf LinkedIn, aber das Original
könnte ein LinkedIn-Post sein.
Not much to say about this topic.
I don't know how lame you have to be
to actually be inspired by this.
I agree. Can we move on to the next topic?
Yes.
Okay, Comment Section
auf LinkedIn ist eigentlich bloß
sich
gegenseitig geil finden im Endeffekt, oder?
in der Hoffnung, dass derjenige dann beim anderen Artikel auch reinschreibt, wie geil das ist.
So go for it, Circle Jerk, genau, ja.
Das ist auch so ein guter Punkt.
Wissen Sie, was auch immer am besten ist?
Leute, die dann posten, this.
Und dann kommt der nächste so much this.
Das ist auf Reddit auch sehr beliebt.
Wow.
Gah, das fasziniert mich.
Ich weiß von der Tatsache, dass niemand in der realen Leben so reagiert.
Das ist nur ein Weg, Gute Wille zu erzeugen und positiv und aufmerksam zu erscheinen.
Sie machen das nur in der Hoffnung, dass es auf ihren kommenden Posten reziprikiert wird,
was Kindergarten mir über B2B-Sales erzählt hat.
Und es wird reziprikiert. Das ist das Schlimmste.
Und es ist ein unendlicher Loop, der nie, nie endet.
Manche hatten ihr Notebook da.
Hier, wir hatten letztens,
wir hatten letztens Abteilungsversammlung,
da hatte keiner sein Notebook an.
Nur ich zwischendurch.
Aber das hatte einen ganz einfachen Grund.
Fragt mich, ob ihr drauf kommt.
Der Grund ist so banal, ihr kommt wahrscheinlich nicht drauf.
Es hatte nichts wirklich mit Business zu tun.
Vortrag, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Der könnt ihr nicht drauf kommen.
Das ist eigentlich nicht möglich, dass ihr Notizen, nein, Urlaubsprotokollschreiber, nein, Urzeit, nein, also ganz einfach, warum ich das Notebook anhatte ist, ich wollte zusammenpacken, um auf die Abteilungsversammlung zu gehen, was sehe ich da, also bei uns ist es so, es ploppen öfters mal Sachen auf, wie es müssen Updates gemacht werden, wollen sie das jetzt verschieben, nicht Windows so von der Firma aus Updates,
so, also so
Device-Management-Updates und
Windows-Updates sind da auch dabei. Es müssen
Updates gemacht werden. Sie können das jetzt verschieben
oder in zwei Stunden. Und da habe ich gesagt,
äh, nee, oder jetzt oder verschieben.
Da habe ich gesagt, verschieben, und wenn du
auf verschieben drückst, kommt,
in vier Stunden
wird das Update gemacht, sie können das nicht mehr verschieben.
Und vier Stunden
war ungefähr
eine halbe Stunde oder, oder nee,
20 Minuten, bevor die Abteilungsversammlung
anfing, um. Und auf einmal hat sich
mein Notebook neu gestartet. Ich wollte gerade zusammenpacken.
Ich habe alles schon in meinen Rucksack gestopft
und dann sagt mein Notebook,
es wird jetzt neu gestartet wegen Update.
Und wisst ihr, was dann kam?
Nicht nur einfach Update, nein,
BIOS Update!
Und das erste, was erschienen ist,
bitte schalten Sie den Computer
nicht aus!
Also, was habe ich gemacht?
Das Notebook zusammengeklappt,
ohne auszuschalten,
in den Rucksack gesteckt und nachdem
mich nur eine Viertelstunde oder so auf der Betriebsversammlung
gesessen, äh, nicht auf der Betriebsversammlung, auf der
Abteilungsversammlung gesessen habe, habe ich
mir gedacht, irgendwie von der Seite
fühlt sich mein Rucksack
ganz schön warm an. Dann habe ich den Rucksack
aufgemacht, das Notebook rausgeholt,
das Notebook hatte gefühlt 150 Grad
und ich habe das Notebook
aufgeklappt und vor mich hingestellt, dass es
fertig Bios Update machen kann.
Das ist nicht abgekackt, das lief
weiter, ja.
Und dann habe ich es halt während der
während der Abteilungsversammlung BIOS-Update
machen lassen. Das ist der Grund.
Ich wollte kein super krasses Business Enterprise
Gedöns machen während der Abteilungsversammlung.
Ja, aber jetzt wollen...
Also okay, dann gucken wir uns das jetzt an.
Der Chat sagt, der Vortrag ist gut.
Das soll man schauen.
Was macht ein IT-Systemadministrator
in einem Alu-Schmelzwerk?
Schafft die Deutsche...
Die Deutsche was?
Hat es noch einen längeren...
Titel?
Ja.
Schafft die deutsche Industrie die Digitalisierung?
Ah, okay, das könnte doch ein spannender Vortrag sein.
Aber was hat dich das BIOS-Update über B2B-Sales gelehrt?
Das BIOS-Update hat mich über B2B-Sales gelehrt,
dass man manchmal einfach durchhalten muss.
Man kann die Sachen manchmal nicht abbrechen,
egal wie sehr man das will.
Manchmal muss man einfach durchziehen.
Manchmal muss man einfach hustlen.
Das hat mich das Bios Update oder B2B Sales gelehrt
War das okay?
Chat, könnte das als LinkedIn Post durchgehen?
Oder war das noch nicht genug?
Der Karriere Kreiselgrind muss einfach weiterlaufen
Das war nur okay
Sehr inspirierend, richtig
Very inspiring
Auf geht's
1080p, gib ihm.
Geht es um die Frage, was macht ein IT-Sysadmin in einem Alu-Schmelzwerk im Herzen vom Pott im 21. Jahrhundert?
Okay.
Es folgen Anekdoten über...
Sagt mir gleich, wenn der Vortrag wirklich losgeht, ob die Lautstärke passt.
DOS-Anwendungen, 20 Jahre alte Server und ein Appell an Vorstände und Chefs...
Moment, nur 20 Jahre?
Auf Datenschutz und Datensicherheit Wert zu legen.
Aluhut, Schmelzwerk, SysAdmin Johannes Bernstein, bitte.
Schau mal den richtigen Keck-Business-Anzug, so ist das gut.
Also erstmal, ich finde es witzig, dass so viele Leute hier sind.
Ich denke mir nur, ihr kommt nach Hamburg und hört euch an, wie jemand anderes arbeitet. Das ist deutlich.
Naja, die Leute kommen erstmal her und sind da und müssen jetzt die Zeit überbrücken.
Aber er hat schon mal die Arbeitssicherheit, wird schon mal groß geschrieben.
Also erstmal kurz zu mir. Ich bin Johannes Bernstein. Ich will euch so ein bisschen Einblick in das geben, was ich mache, in meinen kleinen besonderen Arbeitsplatz.
Ich freue mich über das große Interesse und es ist für mich eine ziemlich große Ehre.
Wisst ihr was, was mir gerade auffällt?
Der hat exakt den gleichen Bart wie ich.
Ist das gerade im Trend, so den Bart zu haben?
Ich habe ja meinen Gordon Freeman Style Bart, habe ich ja schon eine Weile nicht mehr.
Das sieht wirklich original aus wie bei dem Leak Zeig.
Ich war gestern dort, das sieht richtig gut aus jetzt.
Das ist wirklich super akkurat geschnitten, so mit der Rasierklinge auch die Konturen und so. Das sieht jetzt wirklich wie geleckt aus für zwei, drei Tage oder so.
Damit jetzt keiner überrascht wird, um was es hier eigentlich dann immer wieder geht.
So als quasi emotionaler Ablaufplan. Also es stand schon in der Beschreibung, aber kurz nochmal, ich bin Systemadministrator, ich betreue einen Laden im tiefsten Pott.
Lautstärke ist okay, oder?
Ich betreue dort alles von der Maus bis hin zur Hardware und Softwareentwicklung.
Ein richtig echter Full-Stack-Biz-Win-Sack-DevOps-Admin.
Und ich bin dort auch für die Lizenzen verantwortlich und stehe auch Rede und Antwort bei Audits. Es wird beim Vortrag jetzt erst bei Punkt 4 geht der Industrieteil richtig los. Bis dahin ist es eigentlich mehr oder weniger so der normale Spuk und Schrecken eines Sys-Admins.
Und zuerst mal, was machen wir bei uns im Adelsschmelzwerk?
Ich hätte jetzt eigentlich gedacht, wir schmelzen.
Ja, verrückt, ich weiß. Also eigentlich wollte ich jetzt so ein bisschen was erzählen, was wir so herstellen.
Ich gehe davon aus, er ist sogar noch zum Teil Hausmeister, gerade in den Technikräumen.
für fette, geile Anlagen haben, aber unsere Public Relations Abteilung meinte dann nur so,
ja, okay, wir machen jetzt so richtig eine Werbeveranstaltung da draußen,
du erzählst mal, wie geil der Laden ist, das ist leider nicht beim CCC,
das ist ehrlich gesagt sogar ein Ausschließkriterium und dann haben die gesagt,
ja, okay, dann ist das halt Freizeit.
Das ist halt schade, weil die zahlen mir normalerweise so Hotels mit 200 Euro pro Nacht,
einen Q3 mit Sprit. Also CCC-Organe nur so vielleicht 30 Sekunden, oder so.
Ihr dürft es doch rausschneiden. Wie sagt man so schön? Wir nehmen das mal so mit.
Also wir produzieren Muzzeln, Sows und Tegel. Muzzeln, das ist das Richtige.
Alles klar. Das sind einfach im Prinzip Barren.
Die können auch immer unterschiedlich aussehen. Links sind die Sows und in der Mitte sind Tegel.
Ihr werdet sowas bestimmt schon mal auf einem LKW auf der Autobahn gesehen haben.
Da ist flüssiges Alu drin.
Fühlt euch damit, wie ihr wollt.
Jetzt erstmal als Disclaimer.
Das wird natürlich witzig, aber ich will mich nicht über meinen Laden lustig machen.
Muss er jetzt auch sagen.
Das ist ein knallhartes Termingeschäft.
Wir müssen zusehen, dass wir alles immer rechtzeitig liefern.
Wir haben da hohe Vertragsstrafen.
wenn wir das nicht haben, da bleibt immer was liegen. Das ist schon mal klar. Und wir konnten
das alles, was ich jetzt erzähle, innerhalb von zwei Jahren beseitigen. Also eigentlich bin ich
da sehr stolz drauf. Und ich muss dazu sagen, ich wurde angeheuert, um das Ganze zu beseitigen. Und
das hat man gemacht, obwohl ich das eigentlich vieles davon gar nicht konnte. Und ich finde,
das alleine ist schon mal einen Applaus wert. Schauen wir mal, was gezeigt wird.
Aber ich muss jetzt mal kurz einmal noch Pause machen.
Also wahrscheinlich ist es der eine,
der wäre nicht der Einzige dafür.
Es ist immer scheiße, alles an der Backe zu haben.
Weil du kannst dich auch nicht rausreden mit,
das macht ein anderer.
Letztendlich kommen die immer bei dir raus.
Da lastet auch ein hoher Druck drauf.
Und bevor jetzt wieder ankommt, Max, ist doch nicht so schlimm.
Diamanten werden auch unter Druck geformt.
Ich hasse diesen Spruch, ey.
Jetzt aber genug Propaganda.
Jetzt kriegen wir ein bisschen aufs Maul.
Sorry, Kai.
Ja, war fast
für den nächsten LinkedIn-Post.
Also erstmal, warum der Pott?
Ich weiß, ich bin hier in Hamburg.
Jetzt kommt so, ja, du hast vorher in Berlin gewohnt.
Willst du ihn wegziehen?
Ich kann das sofort verstehen,
wenn man aus Berlin wegziehen will.
Also,
Berlin ist komplett lost.
Warum auch immer man da sein will, verstehe ich nicht.
Ich konnte mit dem Fernglas den...
Frankfurt-Brudi, Mensch.
Frankfurt-Göte-Straße, Louis-Vitor-Store,
zahl die Kollektion bar, fick auf Sponsor.
Muss jetzt einfach sein.
Heiko Maas hat dort gerne auf dem Balkon gestanden.
Das ist da oben rechts.
Und wenn man dem zugewunken hat, ist der reingegangen.
Das alleine schon.
Das war mein Arbeitsweg.
Das ist zu Fuß, einmal durch Berlin,
Bebelplatz.
Besser kann es eigentlich nicht sein.
Also warum der Pott?
Ich habe schon lange mit dem Gedanken gespielt, mein Studium auf Eis zu legen.
Ich habe mich dann in NRW beworben und ich habe schnell gemerkt, der Konkurrenzdruck
da ist deutlich geringer gewesen.
Also warum ausgerechnet ich?
Also ich bin Mitte 30, ich habe eine Ausbildung zum IT-Assistenten absolviert.
Ich habe vorher ein Studium angefangen und zwar als Ingenieur für technische Informatik im Bereich Embedded Systems und ich habe ADHS.
Das ist der einzige, den ich jetzt bisher gesehen habe, der mit so einer Assistentenausbildung irgendwas reißen konnte.
Normalerweise dachte ich immer, das ist komplett für die hohe, wie sagt man so, hohle Hand.
Nee, komplett für umsonst, braucht man nicht.
Also das sieht man jetzt schon so ein bisschen an diesem bunten Lebenslauf.
Ich habe auch bis zu der Mitte meiner Ausbildung nie eine Therapie dafür.
Ist doch eigentlich fast nichts Besonderes mehr.
Mittlerweile wird doch irgendwie für jedes zweite Kind mit ARS diagnostiziert.
Wie viel davon wirklich zutreffend ist, steht wahrscheinlich auf einem anderen Blatt.
Elementös durch Globuli oder einen schreienden Schamanen bei einer Alibis-Kapur.
Das hat aber dazu geführt, dass ich dieses ständige Chaos in meinem Leben irgendwie bändigen musste
und dadurch ein unglaublich gutes Krisenmanagement entwickelt habe.
Und ich glaube, ich könnte mittlerweile auch gar nicht mehr ohne Chaos.
Also mit einer Versicherung wäre ich nicht richtig aufgehoben.
Wie? Meint er, in der Versicherung gibt es kein Chaos? Da muss ich widersprechen.
Das Kapitel muss ich unglaublich kürzen. Da gibt es so viele Gründe dafür. Aber ich hatte ein
telefonisches Bewerbungsgespräch und ich hatte schon eine Stelle in Aussicht. Also habe ich
was gemacht, was man eigentlich nicht macht. Ich war brutal ehrlich. Also jetzt nicht so
overselling, von wegen ich bin Putzkraft und das ist Facility Management. Und der IT-Leiter hat
mich dann an einer stelle gefragt wie ich dazu kam so ein proxmox server in der nutzerbetreuung
von der uni aufzubauen und ich habe den dann so ein bisschen durch die blume erzählt wie ich so
ein 40 kilo schweren reg server mit hilfe von meinen freunden halblegal vom laster fallen
lassen habe und er hat nicht aufgelegt er gesagt sie sind perfekt für gelse kirchen ich weiß nicht
ob das unbedingt jetzt für den Arbeitgeber
spricht.
Also,
es spricht dafür, dass sie ihn genommen haben.
Aber
wenn die Server vom
LKW-Fallen gut finden, weiß ich nicht.
Ich dachte mir nur,
ich dachte mir vor allem nur so,
um Gottes Willen, schickt mich nicht in
dieses gottverlassene Loch.
Aber ich war halt auch neugierig.
Und damit ging es dann los.
Also jetzt ohne Spaß, das war echt alles vom Abfackeln.
Also mein Vorgänger, Quasi-Vorgänger, der war da eigentlich als Datenbankentwickler
angestellt und der hat die IT-Lotsune nebenbei gemacht.
Also ich meine, man kennt es halt so.
Ist wie in der Schule früher, wo die Mathelehrer Computerzeug mitmachen mussten und eigentlich
auch keine Ahnung hatten.
Mitarbeiter, so mal eben schnell alles betreut.
Also Fleet Management, WLAN, Fuhrpark, File Server, Datenbanken, Zeiterfassung, Telefonanlagen.
E-Mail-Verwaltung und die Tickets, alles 24-7, macht man alleine.
Also der hat 20 Jahre lang, glaube ich, nicht einmal länger als eine Woche Urlaub gemacht.
Der hatte in Mallorca seinen Laptop am Strand dabei und ziehe ich um.
Und Leute, wahrscheinlich hat der das nicht auf LinkedIn gepostet.
Ich habe mir noch Mut vor.
Jetzt kommt aber das Schlimmste.
Ich muss gestehen, ich habe einen riesigen Fehler beim Bewerbungsgespräch gemacht.
Ich habe nicht in den Serverraum geschaut.
Oh, hab ich auch nicht
Mach das immer Leute
Hab ich auch nicht
Schaut in den Serverraum
Also ich hab beim
Beim ersten, bei meinem aller allerersten
Arbeitgeber hab ich in den Serverraum geschaut
Der wurde mir damals gezeigt tatsächlich
Ähm
Ja und danach der
Der kannte ich den Serverraum ja schon
Bei meinem jetzigen Arbeitgeber
Habe ich auch nicht in den Serverraum geguckt
Was auch schwierig
ist, weil die über, weil jetzt mehrere
Rechenzentren über Frankfurt verteilt sind
und
ich war bis jetzt
auch noch nicht im Serverraum.
Es gibt ja gar nicht mehr den Serverraum.
Ich habe nur von unseren Azubis gehört,
dass es dort wohl
echt,
dass ich mich da überhaupt nicht mehr zurechtfinden
würde, weil die Leute haben
heute Akkuschrauber und einen elektronischen
Hebearm, um was einzubauen.
Das war so das komplett
da kam mir so vor, wie Opa Max erzählt vom Kriech, Alter, das gab es bei mir alles nicht.
Mit Laserschranken?
Okay, vielleicht nicht, aber wenn ihr da drin eine Leiche findet, das ist nicht das Schlimmste.
Gab es keine Unternehmensführung zu einschätzen? Das wäre ein bisschen groß gewesen, ne?
Ja, also das kenne ich auch.
Das ist eigentlich nicht unnormal gewesen.
Gerade dort, wo die ganzen Patchpanels drin waren.
das hier schon, also das ist wirklich sehr
wild, ja das ist sehr wild
das hier ist eigentlich historisch gewachsen, würde ich sagen
bei uns war es so
im alten Rechenzentrum
also wo ich noch beim Provider gearbeitet habe
es gibt ja RECs
äh
Ja, es gibt ja Racks, die haben eine Tür. Also ich würde sogar sagen, die allermeisten Schränke haben eine Tür. Aber, oh man sieht es hier. Also zumindest die, wo dann die, wie soll man sagen, auch alles so schön in Reihe steht mit Kaltgang und Warmgang, da haben die alle eine Tür.
aber unser
Kabelschrank, der hatte auch
eine Tür und der sah
ungefähr, na ganz so krass sah das jetzt
nicht aus, aber
schon
da waren oben Glasfaser
Kabel, das waren die einzigen, die halbwegs
ordentlich waren, weil sie da Schiss vor hatten
Strukturierte Verkabelung
ja genau so ungefähr
also das Problem an unserem
Kabelschrank, der sah wirklich schon ungefähr so
aus. Das trifft's eigentlich,
denke ich, ganz gut. Und
die Tür hat sich
keiner getraut zuzumachen,
weil man
Angst hatte, das wirkt
zu viel Druck auf
das Innenleben aus und es gehen Sachen kaputt.
So ungefähr sah das aus.
Rechts nicht,
so wie links sah der eine Schrank aus.
das ist alles weg also so sehr das gute stück dann aus dem netzwerk schränke waren eigentlich
im prinzip kugelsicher ganz ehrlich wenn man wenn man wirklich die herausforderung mag dann ist das
sicherlich cool wenn man den freifahrtschein kriegt auch wirklich das zu machen was notwendig
ist oder das zu machen was man will und was notwendig ist da kann das schon cool sein
man darf bloß nicht davon ausgehen dass man also ich gehe nicht davon aus dass du
der reich wirst von. Und die Glasfaser
von den Panels, die ging auf so
einen ATX-Switch, der ist da in der Mitte, und der
ging mit einer Kupferverbindung raus, auf
einen anderen Switch, das ist eine 100-Mbit-Verbindung
gewesen. Und die zwei Switche
gingen über 100-Mbit-Verbindungen wieder auf die
nächsten und auf die nächsten. Ich glaube, wir waren bei 75
PCs auf 100-Mbit.
Geil. Bis zu Tode
kaskadiert. Der Rack-Server auf dem Tisch dort,
den sieht man da hier so, der ist
übrigens unser primärer DC.
HP?
Chat, von den Farben her
ist das ein
HP-Server?
Die alten
DL380, die hatten
so eine Farbe. Es könnte auch Dell sein,
aber ich würde
auf HP tippen.
Ja.
War auch der Einzige.
Wir haben da noch mehr so ein paar Relikte,
aber über die möchte ich jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht reden.
Da unten steht, das da unten könnte aber ein Dell sein.
Nee, nee, auch ein HP.
Die neuen HPs haben eher so ein grünes Ding.
Wir haben da noch mehr so ein paar Relikte,
aber über die möchte ich jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht reden.
Also, Bisektionsweite, wer kennt das Wort nicht?
Was? Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Chat, Bisektionsweite.
Das ist mein Lieblingswort aus meiner Ausbildung. Das gibt an, wie ausfallsicher ein Netzwerk ist. Wenn man jetzt ein Mesh-Netzwerk hat, kann ich fünf Knoten wegnehmen, das Netzwerk steht trotzdem noch, nur die Nodes sind weg, dann habe ich eine Bisektionsweite von fünf.
Bisektionsweite von eins heißt, wenn was kaputt geht, ist alles kaputt.
In jedem Bereich eins. Die Server hatten halt keine Updates oder kaum. Wir hatten sämtliche Windows-Versionen.
Es ist quasi ein Rate Null über alles von der Ausfallsicherheit.
Das Hauptsystem lief über einen 2003er Windows Server, bei dem der Explorer alle 15 Minuten
abgeschmiert ist und man hat das alles nur gesichert mit, also man hat schon Backups
gemacht, aber da wurden die ACS nicht übernommen, also die Zugriffsberechtigung.
Und das heißt, wenn es weg ist, ist es weg.
Da habe ich lange Zeit wirklich schlecht geschlafen, muss ich sagen.
Okay, ich habe keine Ahnung davon, weil ich keine Ahnung von Keg Windows habe, aber klingt
schlimm gelöst habe. Aber ich habe da so einen Dienstleister
dafür so verbrannt, der hat das seit 15 Jahren
gemacht und der hat dann einfach
aufgelegt am Ende und hat gesagt, ich meine, es ist Feierabend.
Und was die alten Server betrifft?
Server to Aluminium.
Also ich kann jetzt natürlich nichts von Nein und
bestätigen, aber so ein Ofen ist
heiß und so ein IBM System X
3400 m3 server verschwindet da restlos und das sieht man nicht mal beim filter
das hätte ich auch gerne gemacht als warnung an die anderen server das hätte
ich auch mal gerne gesehen also man hat mir gar nichts gesagt am
anfang also wirklich jetzt ungelogen keine priorität keine anweisung und dann
habe ich das gemacht was mein alter chef immer gehasst hat ich habe mir einfach
arbeit gesucht ich wollte also erstmal so ein dhcp server aufsetzen wir hatten
ein und im zweiten AD-Controller, da lag so ein alter Fujitsu-Server, dann ist der RAID
mal flöten gegangen, hab ich gefixt, den da reingenommen und hab erstmal schön bei
der Domänenaufnahme und bei der Rolleninstallation komplett scheiße gebaut. Und dann kommt einfach
nur folgendes. Ich dachte nur so, scheiße, jetzt gibt's richtig.
Jetzt rüber ins Rennzentrum, Turnschuhe an.
Und ich sag das meinem Kollegen von gegenüber, und der sagt einfach nur so, wir haben nur
Ein Bastler, der fixt das. Der hat das auch gefixt.
Der hat kein Wort darüber verloren.
Okay, er ist glücklicherweise
nicht alleine. Oder hey, was wolltest du
da eigentlich machen? Nichts.
Das hat mir mehr über den Laden gesagt,
als jedes Gespräch mir das hätte sagen können.
Das ist der ganze Umgang.
Aber
AD war da, DHCP war da und alles
war wieder so ein bisschen besser.
Da kamen wir aber schon zum
nächsten Problem und dafür habe ich jetzt
ein schönes Rätsel
für euch.
Es ist Windows, ich kann nicht miträtseln. Es ist Kerberos auf jeden Fall, wenn man nach dem Bild links geht.
Links ist der Kerberos, rechts ist ein Fehler 37. So, jetzt brauche ich mal Wartemusik.
Was ist der Fehler 37?
Failure to launch?
Klar, der Stirnlappen-Basilisk unter den Updates. War ja logisch, kennt jeder. Also um was ging's?
Microsoft hat im November 2021 so ein Patch für eine Sicherheitslücke rausgehauen und der hat
die Sicherheitslücke gar nicht gefixt. Der hat einfach nur munterlustig Fehlermeldungen
rausgehauen. Siehst du, das ist eines der Gründe, warum ich nie was mit Windows-Administrationen
und so zu tun haben will.
Und die habe ich gesehen.
So, ich will da jetzt auch nicht zu viel ins Detail gehen, aber im Prinzip war das so,
wenn du in die Disco gehst, hat der Türsteher eine Liste und da steht drauf, wer wo reinkommt.
Du bist in der Gästeliste, du kommst in den Club.
Du bist auf der VIP-Liste, du kommst in die VIP-Lounge.
Wenn du da jetzt aber hingehst und du legst einen Ausweis hin, auf dem gar kein Name steht,
dann lässt er dich rein und dir gehört plötzlich der ganze Laden.
Dazu muss man jetzt sagen, das ist natürlich nur mit einer manipulierten Anfrage möglich
und deswegen hat Microsoft damit auch nicht gerechnet.
Klar, wie kann man auch damit rechnen?
Aber so vergessene Voidchecks und sowas, das passiert schon öfter mal.
Das ist auch der Grund, weshalb ich beim Verteidigungsministerium in Berlin mal einen Platzverweis bekommen
habe und ein Bundeswehrfahrzeug vom Schwulen Museum im Parkverbot abgestellt habe.
also bevor ich jetzt hier loslege weiß jemand nicht was ein vesos ist aber das weiß sogar ich
das war ich weiß sogar ich dass es ein windows update server irgendwas ist ich weiß aber auch
dass wesens eingestellt wurde das nicht so wurde wesens nicht abgeschafft also dieses server und
Das ist dieses Ding und normalerweise öffnet man die Konsole und dann steht da, welche Updates man jetzt da gerade am Laufen hat.
Und wenn man den mal nicht gepflegt hat, dann sieht das so aus.
Ach, es gibt es wieder.
Das wurde 2019 angeschafft, Ende 2019.
Dann kam Corona und dann hat keiner mehr Updates freigegeben.
Und als man dann mal nachgucken wollte, wie der nun eigentlich aussieht, ist das Kind in den Brunnen gefallen, Datenbank komplett futsch.
Ich bin immer wieder begeistert davon, wie viel Zeug bei Windows-Servern einfach durch das pure Existieren kaputt geht. Das werdet ihr so auf keinerlei Linux-System mit irgendwelcher Sache drauf erleben, dass es durch pures Ansein und Benutztwerden sich selbst kaputt macht.
und
den kannst du nicht mehr retten, im Prinzip.
Ich habe halt dann in der Hauptfilane angerufen
und habe mir nur so gedacht, okay,
darf ich das fixen? Die waren da ganz
locker so, ja klar, wenn du das schaffst, dann kein
Problem.
Ich habe das noch nie gemacht.
Und ich
habe mir nur gedacht, okay, unser Laden, der hat
mehrere hundert Quadratmeter, wir haben über hundert
PCs da drauf, da fahren Stapler mit
flüssigem Alu durch die Gegend.
Und ich arbeite hier seit weniger als zwei Wochen.
Ich fixe den Mesos.
Ich meine, vielleicht auch nicht gut,
wenn die Dinger da mit Windows fahren, oder?
Ich habe da so die Foren durchgewühlt.
Die haben gesagt, ja, Rolle rausnehmen.
Registry-Hack bestimmt am Ende.
Bank löschen, dann geht das.
Ging nicht.
Dann stand da so, ja, net Framework löschen.
Net Framework gelöscht.
Startet den neu, kommt der ohne grafische Oberfläche wieder.
Jetzt für euch alle Leute, keine Panik, das ist tatsächlich normal, das passiert.
Wisst ihr, was das erste wäre, was ich gemacht hätte?
Ich hätte mal gebootet von einer Linux-Kiste und hätte einen Snapshot gezogen von einer kompletten Platte.
Auf irgendein externes USB-Laufwerk.
Manchmal beim Windows-Server, wenn ihr das Net-Framework deinstalliert, dann kommt der ohne grafische Oberfläche wieder.
Ist das so? Warum?
Oh, ja Moment, da fehlt ja Leerzeichen. Da fehlt ja Leerzeichen dazwischen, deswegen geht das nicht.
Der hat den Befehl nicht gefunden.
Wenn man CD Punkt Punkt macht, oder? Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment. Moment,
das funzt? Da muss man kein Leerzeichen dazwischen machen? Windows, Alter!
Es macht überhaupt keinen Sinn, dass es ohne Leerzeichen geht.
Weil guck mal, unter ordentlichen Betriebssystemen geht das nicht. Und das geht.
Ich frage so bei meinem Vorgänger, sag mal ist der Server eigentlich wichtig?
Der Server kann ja nicht so wichtig sein, der war eh kaputt seit Corona.
Als er dann fertig war mit 8 hat er gesagt, ja, da läuft das Software Deployment drüber,
da macht er auch Monitoring und so.
War schon schlecht.
Mit Monitoring?
Keck, wait.
Aber ich hab den repariert.
Der File Server war noch da, dann hab ich den in den Server Manager reingenommen und
hab versucht darüber das Net Framework im Server Manager zu installieren.
Das hat nicht geklappt.
Alter, ich krieg Anfälle von Windows-Administration. Das ist ja grausamst.
Dann kommt das als Dependency rein.
Aber Windows-Administration, ganz ehrlich, für mich sieht Windows-Administration immer, wenn ich davon irgendwas sehe, irgendwas höre, nach dem größten Gefrickel der Welt aus, Alter.
Also die anderen Sys-Admins am Standort haben dann natürlich gesagt, die haben jetzt plötzlich einen tagesaktuellen Vesos.
Ich habe da so ein paar Pauschalskripte zusammen gehackst und so.
Und ihr könnt euch nicht den Jubel von meinen Kollegen am Standort vorstellen.
Es gibt Updates.
Die sind überall aufgetaucht, die Dinger.
Und die haben dann natürlich auch blitzschnell nach drei Tagen, blitzschnell die Rechner neu gestartet.
Und dabei sind ungelogen viele Daten verloren gegangen.
Da gab es richtig Ärger.
Und das nächste ist dadurch, dass das Netzwerk so durchkaskadiert war,
ist durch die Update-Verteilung das Netzwerk gebremst worden.
Also das habe ich dann wirklich nicht beliebt gemacht.
Jetzt aber mal dazu, was ist eigentlich das Besondere bei mir an meinem Standort?
Also das ist jetzt natürlich nicht mein Schreibtisch.
Ich habe einen normalen Schreibtisch im Büro, die meiste Zeit verbringe ich dort, aber ich
mache eben auch sowas.
Da bin ich am Steuer von der Hebebühne.
Das sieht jetzt nicht so spektakulär aus, aber das sind fünf Meter bis zur Hebebühne
und ich bin auch gerade in fünf Meter Höhe.
Also schwindelfrei muss man wirklich sein.
Da fahren auch außen drum die ganze Zeit Stapler und LKWs rum und ich muss auch aufpassen,
dass sie das Ding nicht anfahren, weil dann wackelt es.
Man sieht auch die Arbeitskleidung sehr schön, die hält irgendwie so zwei Kilowolt aus und
ganz viel Brand, aber das macht unsere SIFA.
Ich will das auch nicht testen.
Also ich fahre die ganz großen Pötte.
Ich darf sämtliche Stapler und Hebebühnen bei uns bedienen und die Hebebühne von eben
zum Beispiel, die wiegt zehn Tonnen.
Und die fährt auch durch eine kleine Hauswand durch und das ist jetzt auch nicht übertrieben.
Ich habe damit mal so einen ein Tonnen schweren Muzzlestapel angefahren.
Ich habe das nicht mehr gemerkt.
Ich habe es einfach über meinen Klippern hören und dann dachte ich mir so, okay.
Wir haben auch riesige Stapler und ich darf wie gesagt beides fahren und ja, man ist,
wenn man das darf, überall der Coolste und man kann alles aufreißen.
Wer Monteur ist, den beeindruckt das natürlich nicht, aber ich bin Sys-Admin.
Ich würde sagen, ich fahre selten mit einem Stapler.
Ich dürfte auch gar nicht.
Sitze ich halt rum und schubse VMs hin und her oder so.
Meine Kollegen rufen halt an und sagen, hallo, könnt ihr uns mal einen Monitor an die Wand
anbringen?
Ich mache halt sowas.
Warum müssen wir das auch alles können, dass wir schnell Leitungen verlegen können
und dass wir auch innerhalb von zwei Stunden mal irgendwie was gefixt kriegen.
Ja, okay, verstehe ich.
Wir kriegen alles kaputt.
Also ungelogen wirklich alles.
Und wir haben auch ein schönes Wort dafür, das heißt bei uns Gewaltschäden.
Und meistens geht alles irgendwie so heimlich und leise kaputt.
Am Ende war es dann keiner und sagt ja auch keiner, was kaputt ist.
Die sagen halt einfach nur so, da geht wieder was nicht und dann darfst du schön Detektiv spielen.
Aber zu dem Telefon gibt es eine tolle Geschichte.
Da ist nämlich einfach ein Mitarbeiter reingeschickt.
Es muss auf jeden Fall was Besonderes gewesen sein, wenn sie schon ein Foto von gemacht haben.
Und er hat gesagt, ja, Telefon ist kaputt.
Und er hat das aus der Alurinne rausgefischt.
Da ist flüssiges Alu drin.
Kann man ja mal rausfischen.
Wir haben ihnen dann erstmal gesagt, so, Kollege, das Ding kostet 40 Euro, da greifst du bitte nicht mehr rein.
Und er hat nicht nur ein neues Telefon, sondern auch ein Gespräch mit der SIFA gewonnen.
Wir vermitteln gerne, aber da hatten wir ein bisschen Sorge.
hier seht ihr jetzt mal so einen schönen vergessenen Arbeitsplatz
den habe ich lange gesucht
der wurde noch verwendet
was haben sie da vorne
ein Oszilloskop
ist das ein Modem noch
und ihr seht jetzt auch mal
womit wir da zu kämpfen haben
Und das meiste davon ist eben Metallstaub.
Und ich muss das jetzt hier nicht faken oder so.
Ich habe welche mitgebracht.
Also,
die besten Fälle, die wir damit hatten,
war vor ein paar Jahren, das war leider noch vor meiner Zeit,
da sind dann Flammen
aus den Netzteilen gekommen.
Ja gut, Metallstaub.
Die laufen normalerweise die ganze Zeit im Eidel,
dann war ein Stromausfall, dann haben sie die Teile wieder
angemacht und dann sind die einfach
in Flammen aufgegangen, weil sich da ein Funkenschlag im Netzteil
gebildet hat. Seitdem,
das Teil da hinten in der Ecke, das ist ein lüfterloser PC.
Haben wir seitdem nur noch.
So, jetzt hier nochmal das Thema Gewaltschäden.
Das ist halt eigentlich der härteste Gegner, den wir haben.
Das ist halt ein schönes Beispiel mit dem Kabel hier.
Man sieht, der Kollege auf dem Tester da, der hat schon einen weg,
der stottert ein bisschen beim Phasenzählen.
Und das ist passiert, weil eine Baufirma uns einen Stahlträger
am Zwischenboden eingezogen hat
und die sind dann halt gegen das Kabel gekommen.
Aber da sagt dir natürlich keiner Bescheid.
Und das heißt, da kommt nur, hier, bupp, Internet geht nicht
bei drei Geräten.
Und ich bin da nur hingelaufen, ich habe das Baugerüst gesehen,
umgedreht, sofort zu den Elektrikern gegangen,
das Kabeltestgerät geholt und Jackpot.
Da ist auch nichts sicher.
Also man sieht jetzt hier auf der rechten Seite
mal so die Dimension davon.
Das ist kein dünnes Blech oder so.
Das ist Stahl. Das fahren die einfach um.
Die fahren euch auch Hebebühnen weg.
Also hier auch vor allem diese Kabelbühnen, die fahren ihr euch auch einfach weg.
Ist auch egal, in welcher Höhe.
Und der beste Fall war...
Die Maschinen haben halt genug Power, das merkst du dann gar nicht.
Es gab mal einen Schrank, da sind einfach die Switche da drin geschmolzen.
Die sahen dann aus wie labbrige Spaghetti.
Das geht halt schnell, weil da muss ja nur einer mal so, wie gesagt, so ein Tiegel, ne, 900 Grad,
wenn du den da drunter stellst und so, da ist alles drin gekocht.
Ja.
Und ich dachte schon, bei uns wäre es ein Highlight gewesen,
wo es mal gebrannt hat im Rechenzentrum.
Da ist ja nichts dagegen.
Das ist natürlich bei der Planung Bedenken.
Du musst natürlich aufpassen.
Könnte das sein, dass man dort Tegel abstellt?
Oder ist das tatsächlich so eine Station, wo man die abstellt?
Wenn du das nicht beachtest.
Das stellt uns halt eigentlich vor die zwei Möglichkeiten, die wir haben.
Entweder du kaufst ganz teure Hardware und die hält halt alles aus
oder du machst es halt billig und tauschst es dann selber aus.
Der Nachteil ist, wenn du es billig machst und du tauschst es selber aus,
musst du meistens vor Ort sein und musst Handgriffe machen.
Und das ist schlecht, weil wenn was nicht funktioniert
und du musst vor Ort sein, es ist aber gerade Samstag um 12,
dann bist du Samstag um 12 da.
Das ist nämlich kein Bürojob.
Das muss ich jetzt bei aller Liebe zu diesem Job sagen,
weil wir kriegen hohe Vertragsstrafen.
Und wenn da was nicht funktioniert, dann nützt mir das jetzt auch nichts,
Ich hoffe, das ist nicht freiwillige, zufällige Rufbereitschaft, sondern die kriegen da auch wirklich was für.
Ja, ich habe Ruhezeiten oder so. Klar, ich kann mich da querstellen, aber wenn das so teuer ist, dann gibt es den Laden morgen nicht mehr. Und dann habe ich da auch nichts davon. Also sind mir persönlich da die Ruhezeiten ehrlich gesagt egal.
Rechtsabteilung hört jetzt gerade ganz genau zu.
Natürlich, ne, sage ich hier die ganze Zeit so, Ausfallsicherheit und wir sind da ganz wichtig in den Lieferketten und pipapo.
Deswegen haben wir natürlich auch dementsprechende gesetzliche Anforderungen.
Also halt wirklich gar nichts.
Wir sind ein produzierendes Unternehmen, wie jeder kleine Etsy-Shop auch.
Wir haben jetzt nicht sonderlich irgendwelche größeren Anforderungen, zumindest nicht an die IT.
Die haben wir dafür alle. Egal ob ihr bei einer Versicherung oder bei einer Bank arbeitet. Leute, das hört nicht mehr auf mit irgendwelchen Regulierungen und Anforderungen und Gesetzen.
In anderen Bereichen ist das so.
Die Umweltauflagen, alles das ist klar.
Aber wir haben eine Schreinerbude,
nehmen wir an, für die gelten genau die gleichen Anforderungen.
Wir sind kein Kritis, wir machen nichts mit Krankenakten
und wir hosten auch nichts für andere.
Wir haben was viel, viel Schlimmeres als Gesetze.
Ich wende mittlerweile für Audits genauso viel Zeit auf,
wie für Angebote und Projektplanung.
Und ich mache viele Projekte.
Wir werden davon mittlerweile überrannt.
Und das hat auch ganz einfache Gründe.
Also ihr kennt alle die Überschriften.
Wenn jetzt mal einer wieder so von einem Lieferanten aus Venezuela was gekauft hat
und der ist dann plötzlich doch ganz nicht so sauber.
Der Imageschaden ist halt einfach gewaltig.
Wenn deine Marke plötzlich mit Kinderarbeit oder Sklaverei assoziiert wird.
Wir sind jetzt ein Laden im Pott.
Also bei uns wird das nicht passieren.
Aber man will sich halt absichern und deswegen sichert man sich bei der ganzen Lieferkette ab.
Und das heißt, es wird alles auditiert und zertifiziert.
Und wir müssen es machen, sonst droppt unser Rating.
Also, stellt euch vor, ihr produziert Kühlschränke.
Und ihr sagt jetzt, alle eure Lieferanten sollen mit 40% Ökostrom produzieren.
Dadurch geht die CO2-Bilanz von euren Lieferanten runter und damit auch von eurem Produkt.
Also super.
Wie macht ihr das?
Ihr sagt, ihr schließt euch mit allen Kühlschranklieferanten zusammen und sagt,
wir machen jetzt ein Rating.
Jeder, der AAA hat, der kriegt dafür so und so viel für sein Zeug.
Und wer jetzt ein F hat, der kriegt halt viel, viel weniger dafür.
Das legt ja alles zusammen fest.
Dadurch sinkt die CO2-Bilanz.
Alles super.
Aber wer bestimmt jetzt, wer nun welches Rating bekommt?
Und da wird es halt richtig eklig.
Das ist jetzt nur mal so ein Beispiel.
Das ist auch immer unterschiedlich.
Aber ihr habt das...
Das ist auch wieder so ein selbsterhaltendes Gelddrucksystem, oder?
wo sie dann Berater und Zertifikate und Schulungen und hier und da Zeug erfunden.
Also sagt ihr natürlich, entweder wir setzen es durch oder wir erschaffen eine Zertifizierungsstelle,
die das für uns macht. Nur die darf zertifizieren, wer auditieren darf und wer nicht und wie das
gemacht wird. Ihr wollt natürlich nicht, dass das ein Minusgeschäft ist, also kostet das Geld. Und
Und das bedeutet, eine Consulting-Bude kann dorthin gehen und kann sagen,
hey, ich lasse mich zertifizieren, dass ich für euch auditiere.
Ich gehe also zu irgendwelchen Firmen.
Ja, das ist wieder so ein selbsterhaltender Gelddruck-Kreislauf.
Und die verdienen sich...
Also nicht Gelddruck im wörtlichen Sinne,
sondern Kohle mit Schulung und dann Zertifizierung.
Und dann muss die Schulung ja noch zertifiziert werden.
Das Geld damit, dass sie dann zu den Firmen gehen und sagen,
hey, 500 Euro dafür, dass du das Zertifikat bekommst.
Aber die ganzen Consulting-Buden,
die müssen viel Geld dafür ausgeben,
dafür, dass sie das dürfen.
Das heißt, die meisten davon sagen dann,
ja, wir müssen euch aber noch eine Beratung dafür anbieten
und so weiter und so fort,
weil das sehr viel Geld kostet
und die müssen das mit Beratung wieder reinholen.
Und die Frage ist halt auch,
wie genau die dann letztendlich hingucken,
wenn ihr eigenes Wohl
vom Ausstellen der Zertifikate abhängt und sowas.
Und das macht es sehr eklig.
Und gerade in der IT
sind diese ganzen Audits extrem lässig,
denn bei uns gilt halt nur zertifiziert und dokumentiert existiert also jetzt
als beispiel wieso 8 ihr lasst euch mit prüfprotokoll verlegen super dann kommt
jetzt aber die frage ob der dienstleister auch zugelassen ist und
das ist jetzt egal ob da auf der rechten was für eine krasse bürokratie wieder
drumherum. So ein pinkes Tee
ist oder so. Und dann kommen die China-Chinesen
mit dem Kühlschrank
von AliExpress und scheißen auf alles
und bieten den für ein Drittel an.
Ihr müsst das nachweisen.
Bevor ihr den Arbeitsschein rausgegeben habt,
müsst ihr das prüfen.
Das interessiert die dann auch nicht, ob das irgendwo
zu finden ist. Du musst das wissen.
Wenn nicht, ist das eine Abweichung. Und das heißt,
wenn ihr irgendwas nicht in der Schublade
habt,
Habt ihr es nicht.
Zum Beispiel
eine Mitarbeiterschulung. Hier jetzt mal von so einem
Mitarbeiter, der das immer auf den letzten Drücker macht.
Ja gut, so was
habe ich auch. Das habe ich
auch. Ich muss auch demnächst
wieder Geldwäscheschulung
machen und sowas. Also das ist keine Schulung, wo man
beigebracht kriegt, wie man
besonders gut Geld wäscht, sondern
wie man das erkennen kann und sowas.
Ich habe auch
vier, fünf, sechs oder so Schulungen,
die letztens aufgeploppt sind,
sind bis Ende des Monats irgendwie.
Aber ihr seht schon,
ich bin eine Bürokraft
und trotzdem sind da schon einige Schulungen dabei.
Die sind jetzt schon so,
aber hier an der Tankstelle,
Zapfsäulen,
ich kriege da wirklich Tanken beigebracht.
Das macht unser Kfz-Meister.
Der jammert da natürlich immer.
Und meine Lieblingsschulung ist
das sichere Gehen für die Verwaltung.
Hier, pass mal auf.
Ich hab hier die E-Mail.
Also, was muss ich machen?
Äh.
Da steht jetzt nur eine drin.
Das stimmt irgendwie nicht.
Lass mich mal kurz suchen.
Das hat mich jetzt nämlich grad...
Auch auf...
Ah man, die Suche funktioniert mal wieder nicht richtig.
Alter, was ist das?
Null gefunden.
Kann überhaupt nicht sein, dass du null findest.
Die Suche von unseren E-Mails hier.
Weiterbildung.
Bei uns heißt es natürlich nicht Schulung.
Erinnerung an bevorstehende Weiterbildung.
Ja, und wo steht es, was ich machen muss?
Weiß man nicht.
Fälligkeitsdaten.
Betrugsprävention muss ich machen
zum Beispiel, ja.
Datenschutz.
Irgendwelche anderen Sachen, wo ich jetzt nicht genau
sagen kann, ob ich die vorlesen darf,
weil dann könnte man vielleicht auf den Arbeitgeber schließen.
Ja, die Mails muss ich auch machen.
Das ist kein Witz.
Also das ist nicht, um euch
da irgendwie was mitzugehen, ihr lernt ja nichts.
Aber wie ich laufe, muss ich nicht machen.
Das ist halt nur, damit dann jemand mit verschränkten Armen
neben euch stehen kann, wenn ihr mal hinfallt und sagen könnt,
ich hab dir ja gesagt, wie du laufen sollst.
Mein Arbeitgeber ist nicht so,
aber man kann seinen Kunden sehr gut garantieren,
ja, alle in der Verwaltung können laufen.
Und wer sich jetzt denkt,
ha ha ha ha, ich hänge einfach überall Zettelchen auf,
und dann kann jeder halt irgendwo,
kriegt ja jede Anweisung,
das ist er auch nicht.
Jedes Dokument muss gelenkt sein.
Das heißt, da muss draufstehen,
unterschrieben von, freigegeben durch.
Das ist ein Verfahren, das müssen mindestens
zwei Leute... Alter, was für eine Bürokratie!
What the fuck? Der Sinn dahinter ist,
es soll nicht jeder bei euch einfach nur einen Zettel hinhängen können.
Das kann nicht jeder laufen.
Ja,
alle Mitarbeiter kriegen nächstes Jahr übrigens keinen Bonus.
Alle Leasingfirmen waren, laufen
übrigens ab März aus, schöne Feiertage.
Und dann die Telefonnummer vom Chef.
Das...
Die Mitarbeiter sollen dann sofort erkennen,
das ist aber gar kein gelinktes Dokument.
Und wir wissen alle, wie realistisch das ist.
Das Telefon beim Chef würde einfach Sturm klingeln und das war es.
Bestes Beispiel dafür ist zum Beispiel die Datenträgerentsorgung.
Ich denke, die können alles in den Ofen schmeißen.
Es gibt natürlich Gesetze und Vorgaben,
aber die sind halt eigentlich egal.
Und die sind nur dafür da, dass du beim Datenvorfall
dann am Ende sagen kannst, nee, ich habe alles getan,
damit das bei mir nicht passiert.
Und damit du das vorweisen kannst.
Das gilt aber halt erst beim Datenvorfall.
Wir können halt verhindern, dass ein Datenvorfall passiert, weil wir reden hier von einer Aggregatzustandänderung.
Viel Spaß da was zu finden.
Ich möchte mal den Typen sehen, der da versucht bei einer Masse irgendwie Daten rauszukriegen.
Da gibt es aber ein Problem.
Das ist zwar ein Recyclingofen, aber der ist nicht dafür zugelassen, Festplatten zu zerkleinern.
Tja.
Wir sind halt in Deutschland.
Kann die Zerkleinerungsrate da auch schlecht beweisen.
Da sind immer ganz wenig Festplatten in diesen Muzzeln drin.
Und da kommen ja halt dann die Worte von einem Freund in den Kopf,
der mal gesagt hat, wo ist denn da der Sinn hinter der Maßnahme?
Und wir müssen halt den Regeln folgen, egal ob das plausibel ist oder nicht.
Und da gibt es eigentlich nur einen Ausweg.
Wir müssten eigentlich Open Source Zertifizierung schaffen.
Eben im Prinzip Audits.
Denn bei dem, was ihr eben gehört habt, wenn ihr euch die Bücher dafür kaufen wollt,
die Leitfäden, das alles. Teuer as fuck.
Ihr zahlt bei den proprietären Audits jedes Mal Geld dafür.
Und die sind schweineteuer.
Ich sag doch, das ist so ein selbst erhaltenes
wir-drucken-uns-selbst-Geld-System.
Ohne wirklich Geld zu drucken. Aber das ist
wie bei allen Schulungen und Zertifizierungen
und sowas. Laden kann auch nicht einfach so gucken,
hey, kann ich das machen oder nicht?
Wenn man das
einmal erstellt hätte,
können alle Läden sofort schauen,
hm,
könnte ich nun auch an die
Luftfahrtindustrie liefern?
Oder eben an die Autoindustrie.
Damit könnte man halt vielen kleinen Firmen vor allem helfen.
Meldet euch gerne bei mir.
Ich würde mich freuen, wenn ihr mal Lust habt, das umzusetzen.
Ich kann da gerne koordinieren.
Aber jetzt kommen wir zum Thema Geld.
Das ist jetzt auch das Letzte von meinem emotionalen Appell.
Wenn wir uns jetzt einen elektronischen Stapler kaufen,
kriegen wir dafür eine Förderung.
Das ist auch gut so, der Staat hat ein Interesse daran, CO2 zu senken, den Verbrauch zu senken und deswegen gibt er dafür Fördergelder aus.
Wenn ich jetzt aber versuche, meine IT-Infrastruktur abzusichern, dann gibt mir der Staat einen feuchten Händedruck.
Das ist schlecht, weil so konkurrieren die Unternehmen darum, wer am längsten ohne IT-Sicherheit durchhält und die tanzen die ganze Zeit Limbo.
Und wer von euch hat von den IT-Security-Fördertöpfen von der EU gehört?
Einmal Hand hoch.
Keine Ahnung.
Das ist mir als erwartet.
Ich nicht.
Wer kennt die hier?
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Das habe ich mir gedacht.
Die helfen euch nämlich, für solche Förderanträge einzureichen.
und Deutschland hat das noch nicht ein einziges Mal gemacht bei der EU.
Das hat auch einen guten Grund.
Wir reden von 500 Seiten Projektvorstellung
und das mit Fließtext und mit...
Alter, wir machen es wieder so krass kompliziert,
dass es kein Saal benutzen kann.
Nachbarkeitsstudie mit Tabellen und Berechnungen.
Fangen wir nicht mit Nachbarkeitsstudie an.
Ich sage nur, der Nord- und Süddings-Mainweg Hanau-Frankfurt.
der nach irgendwie 15 Jahren
immer noch nicht über Machbarkeitsstudie
rausgekommen ist. Mit dem Geld, was da rauskommt
im Prinzip den ganzen Industriezweig
sanieren.
Es muss aber eine Partei vorstellen
und dann für quasi
zehn Parteien machen.
Und deswegen, ich werde die nächste Folge sowas von bereuen.
Also falls jetzt jemand hier im Publikum ist
oder das bei YouTube sieht und ein IT-Sicherheitsdienstleister
ist und sagt, hey,
ich hätte da mal Lust, das in der Alu-Branche durchzuziehen, meldet euch bei mir.
Ich mache das auch gerne in meiner Freizeit, denn ich hasse anscheinend meine Freizeit.
Ich muss dazu sagen, wie gesagt, da drin sind Millionen in den Töpfen.
Wenn dieser Prozess einmal gemacht wurde, kann man das auch für alle anderen Branchen machen.
Krankenhäuser, Flughäfen und so weiter und so fort.
Man gewinnt quasi, weil das immer für zehn Kunden zum Beispiel ist,
zehn Kunden und damit auch sehr viele Folgeaufträge.
Ihr könnt damit euer Sock finanzieren.
Ja, also als ich den Vortrag geschrieben habe,
musste ich sehr viel streichen.
Nicht nur lustige Geschichten, aber Lost Tech zum Beispiel.
Also es gibt ganze Industriezweige,
die an zwei Personen hängen.
Und viele Firmen haben in den letzten 20 Jahren
einen so gigantischen Investitionsstau aufgebaut, dass die sofort pleite wären,
wenn die jetzt alle End-of-Life-Geräte oder Software austauschen würden.
Und das wird nicht weniger.
Ich hoffe, mein Werksleiter verzeiht mir dieses Zitat.
Ob der Mittelstand das schafft, das hängt nicht vom Zufall ab.
Wir haben jetzt hier im Raum viele junge Menschen und wir haben viele engagierte Leute.
Sucht euch Jobs, wo ihr was bewegen könnt.
Wenn der dann auch noch ordentlich bezahlt ist?
Legt euch mit den Vorständen an.
Sagt denen, wir brauchen das, sonst gibt es uns morgen nicht mehr.
Die müssen das in den Kosten haben.
Die müssen das in den Kosten sehen.
Prescht nach vorne, bringt euch ein
und hört ganz genau hin, wo die Probleme sind
und löst die vor allem einfach kompromisslos.
Geht in die Politik, geht in die Parteien.
Auch die brauchen euch dringend, auch wenn die euch nicht wollen.
Wenn jetzt nur 100 Leute nach diesem Vortrag da rausgehen in ihre Firmen und da was verändern und daran rütteln, dann verändert sich das ganze Land. Da bin ich ziemlich sicher.
Ich bin da weniger optimistisch
so alteingesessene Strukturen
und wie soll man sagen
so eingeschliffene Sachen
das ändert sich nicht von heute auf morgen
auch nicht durch 100 Leute
weil die Leute einfach faul sind
an allen
Ebenen faul
Noch mal ein großes Dank an meinen IT-Leiter, der den Vortrag möglich gemacht hat.
Und alle Leute an meinem Werk, weil die mich immer als Kollegen behandeln und nicht nur als den IT-Bub.
Und vielen Dank an alle meine Freunde und Verwandten.
Klapper.
Neißer Vortrag.
Chad hat recht gehabt.
Ich hab Hunger.
Nee, das Problem sind nicht die Boomer.
Die Leute, die dann, wenn die Boomer in Rente sind, dann dort sind, die sind auch nicht besser.
Das ist einfach, vieles hat sich so eingefahren und es wird immer mehr an Bürokratie und undurchsichtigen Sachen
und hier muss dann da noch was kontrollieren werden dann brauchst du die kontrolle der
kontrolle und wieder ein des kontrollierten das dann zertifiziert und das ist einfach
teilweise hat das ausmaße das ist problematisch weil keiner will ja seinen eigenen stuhl absegen
keiner der in dieser position ist für sagen ja eigentlich braucht man uns gar nicht
Rudel mit Lachs, ne heute gibt es Spaghetti mit Tomatensauce
Chatge, ich geh mir jetzt was zu essen machen
Ich bin schon über 3 Stunden on
Gehe wirklich saumäßig schnell rum heute
Macht's gut, bis dann
CU